The powerful Dom Arrera is here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I am typing that shit as I talk to you.
That's why I seem like I'm slow.
But I wrote,
damn,
I rera see that.
Damn I that I very character.
Why did he get off at the soda?
Like I told him pill.
John,
my rarer is uh,
one of my favorite human beings on the planet,
but he also drives a car from many decades ago.
Has No,
it is an antique.
Now I'll tell you what,
that car,
would it be worth a lot of money to like a young upcoming comic if they found
out they could get ahold of Don.
My rare is Lexis.
Well,
you know it was,
I called it the share cause I was on tour with Sherra and I got all this extra
cash and it's summer.
So I go in and buy a car.
I said a guy,
I'll give you 40,
$40,000.
He goes,
I can't do that.
And I said,
all right,
it goes,
wait,
come back.
I said,
that's what I'm going to give you.
I can just got a brand new Honda.
I don't need Alexis.
I just want one cause it's cool.
Then went let me talk to my friends and he comes back because you know I like
you.
I'd go,
we just met me.
That's amazing.
I wonder are what quick wonderful relationship.
This is.
Then I got the car.
I paid cash.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a war horse of a fucking car,
but Don Maria has no goddamn navigation system in that thing,
but it looks beautiful.
I listened to the ground like it's like an Indian scout dumped them.
I'm feeling the wheels beneath my feet.
All radio.
That's an evil work and fix it.
I had my radio break once and it fucking,
I thought up more shit that day.
Then and then any other day I like I should break my radio all the time.
The biggest drag or that car is it only has a tape deck.
Oh no it does.
It's really hard to get tapes.
I went into a place and they have no
tapes left.
That is Goddamn hilarious.
You have a tape deck,
but all these other cars I've got it.
I've got a brand new Cadillac for leasing and all that.
Something went wrong with him.
This one,
nothing stops it.
Well,
you know those Lexus's or fucking bulletproof.
You want us as bulletproof time?
I remember.
Oh and and it get yourself some bulletproof coffee.
Mix it up with fresh butter that comes from grass fed cows and the only way to
go on some MCT oil.
Could you repeat that because I didn't get that.
This
is a complicated advertisement.
Okay.
onnit.com o n n I t would you need to do is get some shroom tech sport and your
lifetime Herrera said what?
Shroom tech support.
Oh yeah.
Shouldn't text book.
I just read out.
You need to get some,
I'll give you some alpha Bray too.
I actually have a gift pack for you Jamie.
This is own little boxes in their little gold on it boxes.
I have getting gifts for everybody that magic podcasts now we give them an honor
gift pack and in the honor gift pack that has all sorts of groupie shit
including Buffalo Jerky made with real cranberry hungry.
No,
no,
no.
Hepped up on.
None of these things will get you higher,
but a,
the Alpha brain will definitely,
hopefully,
if it works for you,
it works for almost everybody.
But I believe people,
when they say it has no effect on him.
I absolutely believe them.
I don't know how you're fucking dumb marks.
I don't even understand how mind works.
But I do know that every single ingredient,
if you go to onnit.com there's a whole page.
It's a based on the science behind all of these supplements and all of it has
been shown to increase memory or a aid and test scores.
It's,
they're all just essentially nutrients that help cognitive function.
It's a very controversial thing and because it's controversial,
we want to treat this thing like as evenly and as honestly and as morally as
possible.
It's kind of hard to do when you run a business,
but the idea behind on it is a real genuine and honest one.
And it's to try to sell you the best shit possible at,
at a very reasonable price and make it so that no one feels ripped off.
And one of the ways we do that is we have a 90 day 100% money back guarantee on
the first 30 pills of whether it's Alpha brain,
a shroom tech.
If you try it,
you,
you know,
you use it,
you don't feel like it was,
it had an effect on you get your money back,
you're going to have to return the product.
No one's trying to rip you off,
but we're,
what we are doing is selling you the best shit possible that we actually use
ourselves.
I actually use Alpha brain,
shroom tech,
new mood.
I use these daily hemp force.
I eat that shit daily.
I use all this stuff unless you use a lot of it.
Yeah,
it was a battle rope workout.
Anyway,
go to [inaudible] dot com using code any Rogan and save yourself 10% off.
Have you been playing that fucking game?
We played actually play it.
I play it on the toilet.
I have an Ipad,
uh,
now my toilet that I used an old iPad.
So there's an image I'd like to get out of my head.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
um,
if you play it on the toilet,
I mean you've gotta be real careful of those legs getting,
yeah.
I'm more concerned about the hemorrhoid that it created.
That's how I got it.
I hemorrhoid you have hemorrhoids.
It comes from forcing things.
Is that what hammer was sitting on the toilet too long?
I,
I sit on the toilet like all the time,
but his social life.
Huh?
It's comfortable.
It's warm.
Not have a lot of lettuce in his diet.
I'm sure.
No rough.
She shits or a struggle so much.
Each one's a battle.
Tell me about it a lot.
I,
I poop all the time.
Do you?
Yeah.
This try,
this coffee is just like two poops waiting to happen.
Well that's good.
The one you're not pooping,
you've got a real problem.
Right?
I was watching this show the other day and uh,
oh,
is Anthony Bourdain's show and it was on a Philadelphia and uh,
he was,
uh,
it's,
um,
his other show,
you know,
he's got those two different shows.
Uh,
the one of them is called the layover and it was that one and a,
one of the things in Philadelphia,
they went to this museum where they had this guy would a gigantic colon and
sometimes it would be like six to 10 days in between.
Shifts is getting shit for like six days as colon was enormous.
It was disgusting.
So don't let that happen.
But they find out that he had enormous colon.
Um,
well he was,
he was distended like as he was alive,
he looked disgusting.
They like,
it was really horrendous looking.
And um,
they uh,
they saved it in this museum.
It's a museum of all like fucked up body anomalies.
I have a friend who used to think it was manly,
not the pay and they would drink beer.
He drink like a 10 pack of beer and hey listen,
this is crazy.
He got a distended bladder from it and it,
it has no resiliency to now he has to use a catheter.
So every time it's so fucking sad.
Broke his bladder.
He didn't break it.
He distended it.
So it's so scratched out,
but it can't hold water again.
So he just has to use a call mark.
He imagined himself all the fucking things that happened to us in life.
He did it to himself,
you know,
was he thought he was like Spartacus,
not pay it and that made them strong.
Wow.
That's uh,
that's kind of an interesting approach to life.
Just talking about backfire.
I think I should have beat that has nothing to do with don would playing blades
slinger while you're on the toilet.
I see that kerosene games is one of our new sponsors and they have this new game
called blade runner or blade slinger.
I keep it same blade runner,
two combination.
It's played slinger,
goddammit.
Um,
it's pretty dope.
The,
the graphics are amazing.
It's that is,
that's the actual graphics of the game.
I mean it is really well done and it's not a game that's ported over from a
computer.
They designed them specifically for the IPAD,
iPhone interface,
the way it works with no buttons and touchscreen and everything like that.
So everything works intuitively with that.
It's a fun fucking game.
And it's,
it's a really good deal too.
It's only 299 to 99 and,
and it's a,
it's,
it's fun to apply and kerosene games,
um,
their,
their whole gold,
their whole mission is to make the coolest video games available specifically
for mobile devices.
So that's what they're working on.
Who does the main character looked like?
It looks like you Jamie.
Get at it.
It looks like you bitch.
One of the Jamie,
Jamie,
Jamie employee number two.
Oh,
okay.
Anyway,
blade slinger.
Um,
go get it on.
on the IPAD.
You can get it on the iPhone and uh,
they're working on a version of it for android apparently.
But a do not says Eta January,
February high end,
android devices as well.
Back to galaxy s three.
The galaxy has three from 10,
if you've been playing with it.
Yeah,
I love it.
The,
the map,
I tell you,
man,
there's,
there's only,
there's a few things that android has going for it for sure.
Especially the galaxy s three and one is the Google maps.
Like just having Google maps back,
the original application that's not on the iPhone anymore.
It's so nice.
And on the Google or the the galaxy s three,
the screen's so big and you had like,
Oh nice maps,
big screen.
It's,
but you know,
I'm still playing with it.
I don't know if it's just because I'm so used to the iPhone for the last five
years using the same operating system or if it's just like everything is set up
so nice.
It's very,
very intuitive.
On the iPhone I find like although a android phones I really like,
um,
they can be a bit like windows or once you know where the fuck everything is,
yeah,
everything's cool.
But before then it's like,
yeah,
why is it here?
I would never see this doing are the fuck is that.
I definitely would never go,
hey mom,
get a,
get an android over an iPhone.
Because it is like,
like,
oh,
you have to figure that shit out this defrag.
Well you would if you wanted her to call you and need you.
Right.
You're like real needy.
You would tell him to get an android phone.
That's true.
Just so you have to give her advice all the time.
Yeah.
Anyway,
my advice to you go getting played slinger.
Yeah.
Get it for the IPAD.
Um,
and uh,
support this cool game company.
Kerosene games because they support the podcast and it's only two 99.
My advice to you is you don't need segways Mr. Yeah.
I'm a master at this shit come naturally.
They flow right.
Next week is when I am releasing my standup special next Tuesday,
the 18th.
So,
uh,
I finally got it all together.
Uh,
I know it took a long ass time.
It took a lot longer than I thought it was going to take,
but thanks everybody for your patience and even the people that asked about it.
No one was being douchey about it,
but it was,
yeah,
I agree.
I mean I recorded it in April.
It's finally coming out.
Is this the just the standup special or is there any extra bonus feature?
Some other shit too,
but as of right now,
like it's just a standup special material and a release that you did last night.
If some of that in that.
No,
that's all new stuff.
I thought that was fucking killer last night.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You've got dry.
Really new stuff.
You got the fucking crime and no vagina joke.
That's groundbreaking.
Well,
thanks man.
Last night was fun as Fuck Don.
My rare is here.
Ladies and gentlemen,
this is the end of the commercials.
Use the code a Brogan and go fuck yourself,
Tom.
I rera is here.
God dammit set up a bit old school.
I can't believe I found the place.
One of the greats,
God dammit,
the Joe Rogan experience.
Try by day Joe Rogan podcast all day.
If a one hour into the podcast,
Brian becomes a bundle of energy and super duper talkative.
It may or may not be because he got ahold of some provigil provigil.
Provigil may or may not be.
What's that?
Some stuff that keeps you awake?
I was told to tell me that
the way he looked at me like,
oh boy,
I don't need that.
Like that's one of the worst things you could ever do to me,
Jo.
Yeah,
that's the thing about Comedians,
man.
We'd love to get us sleep on.
Well,
I mean speed would kill me.
Yeah.
I like down.
So I like tranquilizers.
If I was going to do any drug,
I would do heroin.
But what,
from what they say,
it feels like Robert Schimmel told me he accidentally took Adderall once.
He,
uh,
I guess it was someone he thought it was one of his pills after he had his heart
condition.
He had cancer and cancer,
cancer and he had a heart condition as well.
Right.
It was having a hard problems,
you know,
um,
whatever he was on,
whatever medication he is on,
he accidentally take someone else's Adderall while he was worried.
But his doctor said he would help,
would be okay.
You know,
like you said,
you like what is the,
what's the pill that you took?
How many milligrams?
You're going to be fine.
It's just going to take a while.
Just go get them.
He's done.
So he let run it around his house.
He's be organized.
His office,
he said he organized all of his notes and put them in alphabetical order,
like doing shit that he would never do without it.
It makes you think like,
man,
if you could,
uh,
if you could manage that correctly,
if you were a confident that you could manage that Adderall stuff,
it seems like you get a lot of shit done on that.
It coffee gets me high.
Oh,
it definitely does.
Yeah.
I mean that's what it looks.
Especially Starbucks.
I mean,
that's why this stuff is a everywhere.
Everybody's addicted to this stuff.
That was that last night I had two drinks and I couldn't interview you.
You get an Mba.
We were fun.
It was fun.
It's fun.
But I was,
I had to think,
you know,
usually,
I mean with you it's like just flows.
But I'm telling you the two drinks affecting me ever since.
I said I stopped drinking.
I started,
I said,
I thought you stopped drinking.
I did.
I Sat,
but I do.
I stopped drinking and then I have a couple drinks every night almost to
celebrate my sobriety and that's,
that's what happens.
I get higher because I don't drink as much.
And I had those two Irish coffees.
I was,
I was fucking,
how many days a week are you back to drinking a seven?
I actually didn't,
I didn't drink on Monday.
And I told my God,
my God daughter who lives with me,
I go in,
I quit drinking again.
She said,
uh,
it's only Tuesday.
You drink Sunday.
I was like,
I'm over the whole day.
So yeah,
that's a tough one.
Yeah.
He only stopped drinking on hangovers.
You,
you did really well
for several months.
Three months.
And then what happened?
I Dunno,
it just checking those keys.
Dumb.
Sorry,
those keys are on that table.
I'm,
no one will forget.
You just missed it.
I missed it.
I missed the fun.
And you know,
one of the girls that left factory friend of mine,
she said to me,
she called me like basically a pussy,
right?
Right on my Juliet.
And she says,
uh Oh,
what are you?
Are you going to have a couple drinks with me tonight?
Are you going to show me a chip for how long gets bitch?
You quit drinking.
You know what I mean?
Like what a friend,
another friend I played ping pong with and he goes and he'll go,
he'll put a Martini and then my nose.
Doesn't that look good?
Like I have just the opposite of supportive friends.
I have Fred to try and get me to drink.
It's like a reverse intervention.
Why do they do that?
I don't know.
Just for fun.
I mean if it didn't bloat me.
And do you get hangovers?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Okay.
And last all day now for me and he started like the whole day,
like I'll have a hangover at like 10 o'clock at night and go,
all right,
I guess I'm ready.
Drinks just to get rid of
you.
Gotta you gotta really over hydrate.
That's the key.
When you kicked it on,
water's good.
It's very good for that.
When,
when you,
when you feel that headache,
that's,
that's mostly dehydration.
I don't get a headache.
I get nervous.
You get nervous,
like anxiety,
heart palpitations.
No,
just like,
I don't know.
Well you realize you're killing your body slower.
Yeah.
You know,
that's the feeling.
Like you realize your impending doom.
That's a danger.
Be a comedian too.
Cause you can fucking live the life of a degenerate and then be fine by 10
o'clock at night.
And let's be honest about,
I mean,
how much,
how much sobriety is required in our jobs.
You know,
I,
you can go on,
have fucked up and have a great set.
I can go on drunk and not even remember to set and just go on wrote.
I mean,
I hate to do that,
but if I have,
I've done so much standup that I could get.
I literally,
I don't even really from a Hammock,
I never,
um,
I remember watching people when I was younger,
phone it in and we've all seen guys phone it in where they're not really
engaging in what they're saying and not really thinking about it.
And I don't like to do that.
It's weird.
It's weird when you see it,
you know,
it's weird when you see it.
And it's weird when it happens to you too,
and maybe sometimes it doesn't always happen to you on PR,
like especially starting out and developing like along the way you kind of like
realize like,
well that's set went great.
What did I do different?
And this set didn't go as good.
What did I do wrong?
But I remember Rah Ray Romano got offset it.
Uh,
we,
I worked with him at Jimmy's comedy alley.
[inaudible] said,
I love that place.
Yeah.
I middled for Ray Romano back in the day.
It was awesome.
He was a great guy too.
What does a great guy,
he's such a sweetheart.
He hates to follow anybody's drunk,
but he was great about it though.
He was so funny,
man.
He was so goddamn good.
But anyway,
he got off stage.
I mean,
he just crushed for 45 minutes.
I absolutely destroyed.
And then he got off to a job wound that was about the most autopilot I've ever
been.
Really just walked right through that one.
It's like he just,
he goes,
I totally found it in and they fucking bought it.
Hook,
line and sinker.
It was hilarious.
Benefit with him for Peter Boyles,
uh,
you know,
his wife started a cancer fund,
the research thing,
and Ray,
uh,
you know,
it comes up to me.
It's so funny.
Our lives,
he goes,
can I ask you a question?
May sound a little awkward.
I go,
why?
He goes,
did you talk about your balls at all?
Like,
I want to know why it goes,
Oh,
I've got a ball bit I wanted to do,
but I don't want to talk about balls again if you did.
Thanks for checking in with me.
Right.
I appreciate it.
Yeah.
God,
did you ever have that with guys?
Like they say,
oh,
sorry,
I didn't know that you talked to
that and you know,
yeah,
of course.
I don't give a fuck.
Do you give a fuck?
I didn't like,
no,
I don't care if I tell you what I took.
I did a bit that Johnny Sanchez did and I knew that I had to have heard it
subconsciously because I swear to God and Johnny knows me.
He knows I wouldn't take it,
but it was too specific was about Mesopotamia and Persia and Babylonia.
Like it had too many rings to it that I thought John,
he goes,
no,
do it.
Like go,
I'm not going to do it.
Cause I know I had to like I could've been sitting upstairs the laugh factory,
not even paying attention.
Heard it in my mind.
You know what I mean?
That's the dangerous somebody didn't cause sometimes it's not malicious.
Sometimes it's that weird thing where you're working with a guy and they have a
bit that's on the same subject as your bed,
but it's a different bit like all the sudden your friend has a time machine bit
but old out of nowhere.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're like,
okay,
yeah.
Well that's not my bed.
Yeah.
Yours is a def.
Definitely a different bit,
but you're going to do a time machine bit right before I do a time machine bit
that's,
yeah,
I've seen that on the road where you have the Middle Act to do,
I'm going to lack the next night.
All of a sudden has same subject matter.
He wrote anything on your material,
uh,
guys who,
open for you when they're doing that shit.
It's so gross,
so transparent,
you know,
and I hate to tell people what to do,
before the subject matter.
I feel like so,
but you can't,
you cannot,
it's just to you,
you know,
when someone's got actual bits and you know,
when someone is just trying to step on a step on the subject matter,
it's a weird thing that people do when they get competitive with the other acts
that they're working with.
And it just ruins the whole vibe.
Like if you go on the road with people and everybody's having a good time and
everybody wants everybody else to do well,
that's like a great feeling when you're working with a guy and he wants you to
eat it.
And so he's trying to like bury you.
He's trying to do shit to burry you.
That's a weird feeling.
Even imagine that way.
I won't guy that did that to me.
Yeah.
And a New Jersey and he just kept trying to fuck me and I could tell,
you know what I mean?
It's just,
yeah,
that's the area for it.
I had,
mine was in Philly,
my worst case examples in Philly.
I had this whole bit about Madonna and this dude did the bit in front of me and
use Janet Jackson.
Oh,
like did the exact same bit.
I mean it was the same number.
You called her a whore in it.
No,
a tall,
beautiful human being.
Oh,
okay.
We're called the wrong bit.
No,
it was,
uh,
it was just about watching the videos.
A stupid joke.
I don't even remember the exact wording of it.
And watching a video on Madonna video while my girlfriend was in the room and
having to feel dumb questions.
Like if you had to choose our enemy,
I'm like,
Jack,
I want you to be honest.
And they choke.
It's like I would fuck her in front of you over your mother's house on the
kitchen table with her ass and your corn flakes.
So it was a stupid joke,
but this dude had the exact same joke the next day with Janet Jackson.
I'm like,
well that's crazy.
Like you just stole that joke.
And it was,
I didn't know,
you know,
back in the day,
I didn't really know exactly how it,
how you dealt with that.
I had enough material that it didn't matter.
I didn't have to do it.
It was like already phasing that bit out.
But I thought it was crazy.
This guy had like two or three bits.
All of the sudden they were on the same subjects and one of them was like
basically the same exact joke and just reworded it.
Did you ever throw something away and somebody picks it up and runs with it?
I had like a thing where I was talking about I'm not a racist unless I'm in
traffic,
then I become a racist,
you know,
it's gotta be a fucking Chink in front of me.
I know it's gotta be a chink broad.
Right.
And I drive with,
see it is,
it's like,
why would you ever throw that away?
Well,
I,
Gee,
I don't know.
But anyway,
there's an act at the,
at the,
uh,
plant factor now.
His whole first five minutes is about that in a racist and traffic.
So,
wow.
And he heard you talk about this.
He had to hear it.
That's,
that's really pathetic.
Pathetically like motivated.
I've seen guys do that.
I've seen guys take a bit that someone else said in a conversation and all of a
sudden they,
well,
what they don't understand is that a lot of times,
like when you say something in conversation,
you might have already said it on stage or you,
you know,
if you have like a point of view on something,
it might be something you've already been working on for a long time.
And if you lay out the premise like that to a guy,
like that's,
it's just as bad as stealing material.
Right?
But you know,
some things you can't steal.
Like when you were doing the two bits about your daughter,
it's so vivid.
Like you can see that that's a,
I mean,
yeah,
but you know,
I'm not going to tell you that.
That's what makes it so funny,
but it's like perfectly executed in the sense that you see her and you see you
and hear you.
You know,
not,
not just the banana thing,
but the second thing is fucking hilarious because it brings you in to something
that's,
that's what people hopefully can't steal is your essence and your,
your own,
your own life.
You know,
if somebody starts talking about my cousin Johnny,
I know they stole from me.
I know they can fuck around and dance around.
Yeah.
Shit but,
but this is a weird thing with being influenced by people versus stealing from
people because yeah,
we're all influence is like we didn't get here on our own.
None of us get her on her own.
I think what we would,
everybody is always concerned with though is like the honesty of where these
ideas are coming from.
Like you're taking ideas from other people.
The whole vibe of what you're doing is completely different because they're like
the vibe of a standup comedian.
Like what I love about say a guy like you when you're on stage and you're killin
is I know that this is your mind putting all this together.
I know this is like any individual's point of view and expression and I lock
into it and have a great time with your thoughts.
But as soon as I think that you're just parroting someone else's words,
as soon as I think that this isn't something that you've absorbed,
this isn't a part of you as a human,
this is,
these aren't your actual thoughts.
These aren't your actual conclusions.
Right.
This is just you saying some shit.
Well then you lose,
you lose a big chunk of that connection then.
Then you,
then we have a bullshit relationship.
There's no soul to it.
I was watching a guy last week and he really was stuck in the 80s and really
stuck,
you know,
for witness without being able to budge and he was just doing,
he had nothing,
had any heart too.
It was just like,
it Kinda like Rodney did.
It's so extreme that it was funny.
You knew that it was a character.
You knew it was jokes and it was funny because his character is so brilliant.
This guy was trying to act like it was him,
but it was jokey jokes.
Do you know what I mean?
It was bizarre and I thought,
okay,
would you put that away?
What happened is a video of me and I was like 20 years old.
This is so crazy.
Somebody just like,
I just remember
Dama rare from full frontal comedy.
So I'm like,
I wonder if I can find that clip and I just hold it up.
Show on full random.
Aye
did it with dumb.
I've never seen this before.
Oh,
it's terrible.
Don't you dare still leans forward when he screamed.
Flexibility.
Waste.
Oh Wow.
This is crazy.
I love it.
Is Do you know Joe?
I don't know.
It's probably terrible though.
Whatever it is.
And something involved with a penis.
Don't turn it Brian.
Stop it.
Do not.
Last thing I want to hear is my oldest
fuck outta here with that here a minute.
One minute and go to Google.
Go Youtube it yourself.
I don't listen to myself,
man.
The last thing,
even my special,
like I didn't listen to it until last week.
I would like a a day to,
uh,
to edit it and I watched it for the first time that night.
Yeah.
I don't like watching myself.
I don't either.
I like,
I do it for the purposes of working on material.
Like I'll listen to the recordings and I do learn shit when I watch myself.
Like what,
what I think is more effective,
like what pauses are more effective or moves and more effective,
like,
and you can incorporate what you,
you figure it out from watching yourself.
But it's like,
it takes away from a lot of the fun of the improvisation of it all.
Yeah.
I don't want to watch myself.
Do you mind if we watch?
No.
Well you might step it out for a minute.
I cannot wait to watch it.
I just,
I'd never seen that before.
You kill up in Montreal.
Dom and I became friends because,
uh,
we did.
Uh,
we did,
what was it called?
What was,
it might've been called the danger zone.
Danger zone from the danger zone or something like that.
Uh,
it was in Montreal at the club Soda.
Yeah.
And that was the first time I met you with it.
That was my first like real TV credit,
I think.
I think I did.
He did MTV half hour comedy hour before that and then I,
but I didn't really care about that one cause I couldn't swear.
You know,
so I want to do a real one.
That was like my first real set and then dom and I met again an Amsterdam
billiards and that's when we fell in love.
Yet we found out that we played pool.
Dom and I played pool.
We were regulars at a set of established that will remain unnamed.
Look at that guy,
young chap from 19 it's like I got a wig on it.
Look at the fucking moves.
He's got stomach three it'd be 64 inches long.
I don't even remember that.
Right about this guy.
He got hit by two trains in one day.
Listen,
listen,
we don't have to do that to you.
Isn't it weird like seeing a recorded version of yourself?
I was like 50 pounds lighter with the big head of hair.
Dom Irrera listen.
Well we need to do is get you a podcast first of all.
I got a podcast.
Yeah,
been on it.
I know,
I know.
Listen,
let me finish.
When you have a podcast,
what I'm saying is we need to get you a podcast that just deals with you not
drinking.
All right,
I'll podcasts where you just,
you get all or any,
any like momentum you have,
any motivation that you have to drink,
any like release a podcast about it.
Release a podcast about why you want to go have a drink or why you don't want to
have a drink.
And I think people would be absolutely fascinated by the struggle of it all.
Cause you're very open about it.
You're very honest about it.
Every time you've come on the podcast when you haven't drank and you were
telling me how great your field and then now you're like,
Eh,
it's too fucking fun shit.
I'll be your cohost.
And I try not to judge told the,
you know,
like in a young Frankenstein when gene wilder says no matter what,
I say don't do not open that door.
And he walks in to talk to the monster.
Remember that?
Yeah.
Well,
I said to Noel last night at the laugh factory said,
do not give me a drink,
another drink.
Are there any circumstances?
I come back 10 minutes later I'll take another drink.
He goes,
I don't know what to do.
You just told me that to give it to.
I said,
forget about what?
don't you gotta listen to me.
I'm a drunk.
You can't.
Um,
um,
I mean you can't keep like seesaw on like that and I think maybe doing a podcast
would be a good catharsis.
Well,
a good sort of a method to try to stay sober if you really want to.
I mean,
if you don't want to look,
I would never try to go to Stan hope and tell him a sober up.
She hasn't.
Why can't imagine him sober?
He doesn't want to do it.
If he wanted any.
And if you wanted to do it,
he could do it.
He can do it anytime he wanted to.
He could.
He could do it tomorrow if you want it to.
He couldn't.
Mitch Hedberg was the one I tried to reach out to.
Really?
Yeah.
Because he,
you know,
he was killing him,
so obviously,
but I mean,
you know,
I didn't know he was doing heroin well.
I was worried.
I think statistically heroin safer than alcohol.
Really?
Yeah.
I think,
um,
I think alcohol is a,
it's a really dangerous shit.
We just don't think it's dangerous because it's everywhere.
It crushes your immune system,
but it also makes you feel great too.
I've got a couple of whiskeys,
senior sweet home.
Alabama comes on me.
I think that's the secret is going back to beer for me.
I think I need to just go,
I used to only drink beer then I just got on this Jack Daniels kick out of
nowhere and I'm just like,
why am I drinking so much jack?
I could through almost 75% of bottled and no,
I think gunfighter in the old west.
Yeah.
I drink like whiskey now.
Me Too.
That was that about,
I like it.
It makes me feel like I'm alive.
I love that feeling down your throat.
Whoa.
Yeah.
I had a shot last weekend before I went on stage and Seattle.
I did that.
A parlor live,
if you have to do that place up there,
it's quick right club.
They uh,
that area of Seattle,
Washington,
it's called Bellevue to a suburb is fucking beautiful out there.
It's so beautiful.
Northwest.
It's incredible.
And it's so like,
it's all like,
it's very like high end stores and Nice area.
I guess that's where like Microsoft is or something to,
Huh?
Shit.
Load of that paper up there.
Mercer island making that big paper.
What's Mercer Island?
That's an island up there.
My girlfriend from college lives.
Yeah.
Really?
She lives on an island.
I still go out there and give it one feeling.
Put a theme,
that graph offer for college.
It's still slam it to,
I know she imagined.
She looks much older than me now.
That's,
you know,
it's sad.
We get so program like no matter what I look like,
I,
I still,
I can't get a fucking hard on unless the chicks young and hot,
I'm done.
I thought,
you know what I mean,
I'm fucking done.
People would call you shallow.
I have to go to another country.
I am shallow,
shallow,
like I don't care.
You know,
I don't care what it girls accomplished.
I care about her looks.
I don't care what you got.
What a phd in philosophy.
Talk to me baby.
I'm hard as a rock.
You not sexually right.
Not Sexually.
I mean I,
I'd be interested in the person.
Yeah,
there's that quote.
Um,
fuck who said that quote,
goddammit.
I forget who it was,
but he said,
um,
all I need from a woman is to be attracted to her.
Everything else I get from him,
man.
I think it was George Harrison.
Really?
Yeah,
I think it was George Harrison said that.
I think I've always attributed to George Harrison,
but it did Google and I couldn't find it,
but I remember reading it somewhere really,
really a pretty positive.
It's him.
It's as a whole bit about it.
He has a whole bit about,
um,
like a that like if you really wanted to hang out with somebody,
you know,
if he was on a deserted island,
he would want it to be a woman.
Cause cause he gets fucking bored of talking to her.
You know he's not compatible like yeah.
If you want to be attracted to a woman like unfortunately for the male
reproductive system and we get our bodies get triggered by young fertile women.
It's an amazing hell interesting.
They'd become like a leave so stupid and I find it riveting.
Fuck,
he never said an original thing in your life.
It's just so crazy that are,
our bodies are like programmed to that where rationally your,
your consciousness,
the idea is like if we're going to evolve,
your consciousness should be able to look at that and go I have nothing in
common with his 23 year olds drive.
What I need to be doing is dating at 50 year old woman like myself and you know,
and go out and enjoy our last year's together.
Let's go get a beer.
But you if you,
you know,
the problem is like if you were still in the sex and he's still,
your body unfortunately wants that.
It does shape body.
Dick does not lie.
It did.
It's like you feel so shallow and heart.
The I seriously am shallow.
I mean,
I pride myself on my shallow,
shallow in a year or whatever it is.
Michelle,
this lack of depth with this,
the girls that are easy on the eyes are never easy on the heart though.
Oh,
beautiful.
You are
good reads you the eyes.
I say unto Thee Brian,
year before our balls,
the fucking lecturer frick you.
No,
you're fucking toilet seat.
Beauty on the eyes.
I love it.
Okay.
So have you been in starting to come out?
Have you been in love twice today?
No.
I mean real love where you live and eat and sleep.
Yeah.
I fall,
I fall deeper in love really fast actually.
So that's,
yeah.
You don't,
no,
no I don't.
I mean I have been like Kinda married four times in my life,
but only you get married once,
but yeah,
Dom's been in some situations before.
He's had some struggle.
Well,
the CRA,
the one extra person.
Horrible.
Craziest.
I can't even do that.
That the whole thing with the house and all that other number.
How many of them had green cards?
Yeah,
yeah.
How many had green cards?
Time?
They were all,
uh,
citizens.
I was proud to say
not of the United States,
but do you feel bad for like a chick that has to date a comedian?
Like for the most part,
like why would you want to date crazy fucking comedian?
Because comedians are like some of the brightest people I've ever met.
So I think that,
see that's the difference.
We're just going back to,
they find that attractive.
You can get women because they are,
uh,
they're just shallow in a different way there.
They,
you know,
they,
they couldn't be with a guy who just a good guy,
they have to laugh,
you know,
especially like,
like these models.
I remember working at the river cafe when I was parking cars and the models,
nobody asks them out because there were too fucking hot.
Right.
So they were alone all the time,
you know,
and like they,
nobody was attracted to them or no,
I guess people were afraid of them,
you know,
they just didn't want to get shot down.
They didn't think they were.
Yeah.
Have you ever been in that situation before where girls,
you just felt like a girl was too good for you and you couldn't even try?
I,
I'm that thick.
No,
never.
Even when you were in Denver,
you know,
I tried everything and I've gotten girls way out of my league just being funny
and honesty.
Well,
you've been a comedian for so fucking long to,
it's like you probably don't know her weight.
You probably don't remember what it's like to just be a out there in the free
world.
But I was,
I was like better looking then I was better as I got less good looking,
my,
I got richer and more famous.
Right.
You know what I mean?
So it kind of balanced off,
you know what I'm saying?
If you go to like a third world country,
you'll press the Fuckos Kailand I'm big,
big dial in.
I think with the kids.
I enjoy it though.
I mean,
I,
I w you know what,
we've talked about this a long time ago and I,
you know about how hard it is as a comedian and especially when you go on the
road and you know,
cause I try not to do anything with the waitresses,
waitstaff,
seriously.
I,
so I'd rather have like a,
you know,
if I'm going to be with somebody,
I'd rather it be like a,
uh,
some nut from the box in the supermarket.
It comes to the show.
But the,
for them,
like it's a thrill to get a guy like Tom Herrera cause like,
oh this crazy ass holes coming into town.
You get to toss their world upside down for a couple of days,
give her a kiss on the cheek and,
and you don't name drop,
you don't Brag and name drop.
They love that.
They love when you don't.
How come you didn't tell me that?
Well I don't think come up,
you know what I mean?
Like it's a very,
it's an interesting kind of trick because you really like Whoa,
withholding the bragging to make you look,
you know,
humble brags seriously.
If you ever seen humble brags on Twitter.
It's a really funny,
I'm in the humble brag book.
You're in the book.
I said something like,
are you serious?
Just published his book and somebody's like,
dude,
you're in this book.
That's hilarious.
What is that though?
Is that a website or not?
It's like a Twitter tag.
Humblebrag when someone says something like,
wow,
I can't believe I got nominated for this today.
I totally didn't expect this.
You know what I mean?
Well,
yeah,
you just letting everybody know you got nominated with your like fake self
deprecating booze shit.
I hear this right here.
It says,
uh,
so Thursday I met John Mayer.
Friday I met 50 cent this rate at this rate tonight I'm smoking weed with Jim
Morrison and Terry Shiloh.
That was at a homeless on a hump.
Their kindness.
I truly don't get what this means.
What does it has the cadence,
what does it say?
It has the cadence.
It's cut off whoever took this picture,
but it really doesn't stack up well.
Whoever wrote that dumb,
you're dumb person.
You don't,
you don't understand what he's saying.
He's a regular guy who met some famous people.
You fuck,
I truly,
during Tet with this with me,
it means you're a cunt.
Yeah.
I met John when you're doing comedy,
which was we was doing comedy at the store for a while.
John Mayer.
Yeah.
You asked me about Connie Mcshane.
Paul's,
yeah,
that's right.
Yeah.
Louis C K scary.
We used to do is thing in Montreal.
It was so fucking funny where I literally used to love it.
Oh Shit.
That's,
is that your phone?
Your phone is the Beatles,
but he got a bad song.
I was like,
damn,
dom Irrera sorry.
He's got one of them old flip phones to,
Oh,
I got an iPhone.
I got the first $5.
It has no navigation up in that car.
Has No idea where he's going.
I had to text him directions.
God helped the people that were behind him as he was reading that shit.
People are twittering,
tweeting.
Oh,
there you have it set up so that when people tweet to you,
it goes to your phone.
I don't know that it's not good.
Daughter did it worse.
Do you want to change that right now?
Because these fucking animals just found that shit out to kill your battery.
Better.
Shut your phone off son or change your settings.
Yeah.
Shut that shit off.
Cause when it's going to explode,
when it comes back on,
they just found out they could get you.
People just found out they could reach
you with just a tweet.
Do you understand that?
That's insane.
You can't let them do that.
You know when I first got your phone will explode about Israel.
No,
you just got back,
right?
I didn't go,
but I didn't go.
Everybody in my family this,
you know when it peaked,
right?
Remember when it peaked like the,
the danger and they said they didn't up.
There's going to be a war and then they started the bombs hit Tel Aviv and
Jerusalem for the first time in 40 years.
I remember that.
Yes.
Okay.
So I had to make a decision and Jeremy Hotz was coming with me,
terrific comedian,
cannon and a w.
I said,
look,
I'm going to pull out because my whole family doesn't want me to go.
All my friends don't want me to go.
And the guy says,
but give me three days.
I said,
what does is fiddler on the roof three days?
Like you're going to,
what are you going to talk to the Palestinians?
You know,
the promoter.
So he says,
give me three days.
And I said,
look,
he goes,
don't watch the news.
It will poison you.
I said,
that's like saying that hurricanes come and don't watch the weather channel.
It's depressing.
Anyway,
so I canceled and it'd be giving them enough time.
There was an article in the,
in the Jerusalem Post about how like we were,
we didn't care about victims from terror of terrorism,
you know,
it's just the opposite.
I was the only took the gig because they were,
it was helping people,
you know what I mean?
The article about you don't care about it added me and Jeremy and the guy who
promoted it,
I'm not going to name him,
but he didn't,
he posted it four times,
you know,
and then he said,
he didn't realize about you.
Write it down on a piece of paper and slide it over here.
And I'll name him.
No,
I don't want to do that.
It's not worth it.
Well,
okay,
let's not name him then,
but it's not about any asshole that,
that it's mad at you cause you didn't want to go to a war.
Yeah,
until my brother is a colonel in the marines.
My brother Joe,
he's,
he's almost a general,
he's done that hand.
The house,
the house combat crazy shit.
I told you that.
Yeah.
He told me,
he goes,
hold on a second.
He looked something up on the computer hotspots in the world.
He goes,
I take a rain check on this one.
And he told me not to go.
He told you not to know.
And he said it because my other brothers said,
all right,
you're caring.
Brothers says one thing,
let's call the crazy brother.
And the crazy one said,
don't go.
Yeah.
You know what the issue is dumb.
It's like so far everything has been,
the casualties have been capped,
like at least mildly in check.
But it doesn't mean that someone can't do something fucking crazy.
And it might not happen.
And it might be,
you know,
a few people die here and few people respond and die here and might be the way
it's coming on or might be an event.
Right.
I'm totally sympathetic to these people too.
It's not like I do care and sterilely situations for refrigerator.
No.
And I was afraid of not getting bombed.
That's so random.
I was afraid of the airport getting bombed and stucked yeah.
Getting stuck there and you have to think about that,
cause it's not like I can go to Damascus can catch a flight.
It's not like,
you know,
if you're in Europe and they're an airline goes on Air France goes on strike,
you just drive to Spain.
Yeah.
But it ain't like that in the Middle East.
It's not like that at all.
And that is one of the that people use.
If they're attacking a city,
they'll attack the airport.
So they keep us goods the,
anyways,
yeah,
that's what they do.
It's this is,
it's a very,
very volatile situation.
And you could have gone over there and you could have been fine.
Oh,
he could have got over there and you could have died.
Yeah.
It's like that's reality in those parts of the world.
It's like we have this sort of a ridiculous notion that,
uh,
because we're safe over here because a wood that we don't really have to think
about that shit too.
Well,
the world is smaller now.
There was a time when it did mean a lot.
Like,
you know,
the fact that we were isolated over here,
away from Europe and Asia,
you know,
as far as fighting.
That's why,
you know what I mean?
There was a time when it now everything's so instantaneous.
They would,
they could get inside people.
Terrorists could do something here if they want to do,
I'm one's been watching homeland.
I haven't seen him live.
Good fucking show.
You know,
I was with one of the leads last week and then not to be a name dropper because
I don't even remember his name.
Russell Peters.
We were going to have the dinner and uh,
to be an excellent,
Peter's knows everyone famous.
He's fucking hilarious is and having a party.
Here's my number.
Mix Master man.
Come up.
He's the only one that brought a posse to my podcast.
They said,
Russell,
you bring,
bringing a fucking posse.
Brings posses everywhere.
Nice House too.
Can I plugged that podcast?
Dom Rare live from the laugh factory.
Let's talk about doing another podcast.
Let's talk about doing a sobriety chronicles.
I'm telling you,
it'd be hilarious and it would be a method to keep you from drinking.
I know you don't want to drink because I know how you felt when you weren't
drinking.
When we're talking,
we're playing pool,
you're like,
I feel better.
I feel I'm just nice to not feel like shit and I'm able to up quicker and ping
pong.
I'm sure you can tell much better.
I felt dumb.
You don't have to drink to have a good time with these clubs,
you know?
And uh,
I'm,
I'm not saying that you should try pot because,
uh,
you,
you don't need to even change your state of consciousness if you don't want to.
I can.
I still do Xanax.
You tell me why one.
No,
no,
it wasn't good at that stuff.
I'll tell you Joe,
I don't know though.
You're listen,
I'm sure I don't need that.
It's hanging out the club to impossible not to drink.
I tried every day.
I'm at a comment,
hey,
you just see everyone else drinking.
I'm laughing and having fun though when you're on the road.
I went to the laugh factory last night and I had some water.
Yeah,
you can go up and have fun,
man.
You don't need to.
All right,
so this is my life.
I'm in Australia.
I'm at the Sydney Opera House,
right?
One week,
the next week I met Mr Magoo bees.
Joe Cass and I'm alone.
But the girls are nice.
I'm having a drink with the money.
You know,
what do I do?
I go back to my,
well,
sometimes it's fun.
Look,
I'm not saying you shouldn't drink.
I love drink.
Yeah,
but I,
I agree with,
but I don't do it every day.
But you're in a lot fucking better shape than me.
You know,
you can drink.
I shouldn't drink.
Well,
even me,
I feel it.
I feel it when I drank and I feel the difference in my body.
It's just not good for you.
It's not smart.
And I don't,
I don't have an issue with it.
I can take it or leave it.
I like it.
Look with a meal.
I like some wine with a meal,
but I can take it or leave it.
What I,
what I think is important though is when you can't take something or leave it,
when you have to take it,
that's sort of a situation where you've got a really wore,
well,
what is this thing doing to me?
Is this thing that I can't take as helping me?
Do I feel better or is it fucking with my whole life?
And for you,
I think it fucks with your whole life,
you know?
And I agree and I love you and I,
I love seeing that you were sober,
you know,
and you know,
I'm not captain save a hoe.
I mean,
you do whatever the fuck you want to do.
You know how I am.
I give people advice if they want it.
And I,
you and I have had this,
uh,
this conversation many,
many times and it never really told you what you should do or shouldn't do.
I sort of just let you talk and you know,
and asked you questions and,
but if,
if you wanted my advice,
my advice would say,
you gotta stop drinking.
It's not good for you.
How they look great.
But it's,
uh,
it's one of those things like some people can have a drink every now and again
and some people can't do that and all of a sudden it creeps up and becomes your
whole day.
Yeah.
Well it doesn't become,
but it does.
It's definitely creep back up.
But for you,
you were doing like drinks in the morning like,
oh,
that was awhile ago.
Yeah.
But that's,
that became your whole day,
right?
No,
not my whole day.
I mean,
I would do a drink in the morning on a plane,
but I wasn't sitting at home having a shots before I get out of bed that night.
You know,
not like last weekend kind of thing.
Will you drinking alone?
Yeah.
Oh,
I love it.
Why are you sitting on a toilet?
I mean,
look,
people
that liked to drink and like,
this is annoying man lift to go and beat him.
So good.
Good drink.
Um,
I just,
I didn't know what you,
I know you're,
when you're reaching out a little bit,
and I know when you keep mentioning this stuff,
it's not because it's not fucking with you.
Yeah.
You know?
Well,
you know,
we go to that pool hall,
I don't need to drink.
Right.
I'm fine.
You know,
just racking a boss for you,
I guess.
Be a good shame.
Well,
you,
um,
you know,
started playing better too.
Yeah.
Everything works better.
So I go look drunk.
It's fun.
I enjoy it.
I enjoy it,
but it's got,
damn,
it's bad on the bottom.
Nobody ever says something like,
Hey,
you look good.
What are you drinking again?
Really got it together.
But it's not,
you know,
they say like a glass of wine every night and it's not even bad for it.
And matter of fact,
it might be beneficial,
an ounce of alcohol,
whether it's in a beer wine or it's supposed to be good for your circulation.
Well,
you know,
people used to drink wine with food because they thought it prevented food
poisoning,
prevented travelers poison travelers sickness.
They would call it because back then when they were traveling around those
assholes with drinking wine out of like animal skins and showing like that they
made like these flasks out of animal skins.
That's how they drank their wines.
I rationalized too because I go,
I only had two drinks but they're two martinis are like eight shots each of them
and there are two jumbo drinks to imagine how hard it must have been carried
food back then.
I mean they probably all got food sickness,
you know,
because Oh my God,
how long was meat stay good.
A couple of hours after he killed it.
I mean,
how many of you have a day?
What do you have?
And it's 80 degrees outside.
Do you have two days?
I know that's a question you have about,
uh,
people bitching about it.
The plane being in a half hour late,
right.
And comedians say like,
Oh,
you actually trying to write a bit about it because the idea of taking a year to
go across the country and you know,
getting stuck at the Donner pass because it's snow.
How fucking crate.
Imagine like,
where are you going?
I got to go to bed.
I've got a Gig at San Francisco when?
Oh,
next June.
In a year.
Oh,
really?
You better get some rest.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
yeah,
we just take it like,
fuck the half hour late,
son of a bitch.
Well,
you want to really wrap your head around a crazy number.
Here's the,
here's the craziest number between the,
uh,
v Invention of the airplane and the dropping of an atomic bomb from the
airplane.
It was less than 50 years.
Wow.
Talk about a life change in that.
Yeah.
Hitler fucked up.
Hitler fucked up shit.
It never really needed the Jews.
They want it for us.
Bernard von Braun.
Yeah.
Well,
yeah.
Oppenheimer,
right?
He was the guy that created it.
Wernher von Braun was the NASA guy.
What was his name?
The guy that did the atom bomb?
No,
that's Oppenheimer.
Wernher von Braun was,
um,
the guy who supposedly got us on the moon,
son of a bitch.
He's the guy from operation paperclip.
The,
uh,
all the best Nazi scientists from,
or Jewish.
We're Jewish,
weren't they?
At first they came over there.
I Dunno if they were not a,
but all the best.
Nazi scientists were a sort of a distributed between Russia and the United
States after World War II.
And,
uh,
America started,
you know,
they,
they started with Wernher von Braun.
They got Wernher von Braun and all these different Nazi dudes under operation
paperclip,
but they were all like legit Nazis.
That's one of the dark secrets of the American space program.
There was,
it was run by Nazis.
Wernher von Braun was a legit Nazi,
like if he was alive today,
the Simon Wiesenthal Center said they would prosecute him for crimes against
humanity.
Wow.
Apparently he had a rocket factory in Berlin and there was this guy who did this
documentary on m and a,
the Moon landings,
and he interviewed,
uh,
people that worked in the rocket factory.
This guy had tattoos from being the concentration camp and he talked about how
wonderful I'm Brown.
Like they would hang the five slowest Jews in front of the rocket factory every
day.
I think it was like really dark,
dark education lunch.
It's not,
I mean,
that's beyond hate in humanity.
It's like that regime,
that Nazi regime there,
that ruthlessness also yielded some incredible science.
I mean the scientific achievements,
it just in the rocketry and engine engine building and you know,
the,
the shit that they were able to do.
And then Russia scoop some of them up and we scooped some of them up.
And that's where the autonomy it was invented here.
Yeah.
Manhattan project.
That was Oppenheimer.
It was that he a,
I mean,
it sounds pretty Jewish.
Is Oppenheimer Jewish.
It must be right,
of course.
Of course.
Let's not forget that the best speaking to Jews,
I'm Christmas Eve.
I'm doing it.
Do what?
His synagogue,
the synagogue and a,
uh,
the laugh factory has a show,
a Jewish show.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I love that.
Nice.
Um,
you have where you have a Gig on New Year's Eve,
where yet?
Um,
at the,
uh,
good nights in North Carolina.
Oh,
that's right.
Yeah.
Which I'm really looking forward to not only the club,
uh,
but my family's down there and Mike,
I got a lot of friends in Raleigh
so I'm looking to see if he was Jewish.
It does not say,
dammit.
We showed this on a podcast before.
That is not to experiment with the dog head.
Yeah.
They had electrical impulses into the dog.
Hadn't made it move after is detached from the body.
Oh yeah,
they did some banking look that looks real right there.
Yeah.
That dog is alive.
Do they did some crazy shit.
The Nazis did some crazy shit and they were really obsessed with the cult.
That's,
that's really weird.
I wonder how much of it is uh,
you know,
um,
sort of revisionist bullshit that like these reality TV shows try to,
uh,
to do these sort of half documentary type shows.
Like I love,
um,
ancient aliens a fun show,
but the reality is they get a lot of shit wrong.
Like they're not trying to be like super duper accurate about some of their
stuff.
And so like when they say something like that,
the,
that the,
the Nazis were really into the call.
I really wish I knew how much into the cult they were.
That was a theme of like Indiana Jones and the template.
You know,
remember the old Raiders of the lost Ark when they found the Ark of the covenant
that was supposed to be the Nazis were after all this a culture.
Yeah.
Apparently they had like a reputation.
I really,
we should educate myself on that.
Find out how,
how deep that was and what the fuck that was all about.
But this guy,
uh,
Oppenheimer,
one of the creepiest,
you look at it that now.
Yeah.
When he,
uh,
when,
when he blew up the,
the nuclear bomb,
he,
uh,
he quoted the Bhagavad Gita is this ancient Hindu religious text.
It said,
now I am become death.
The destroyer of worlds.
Wow.
Could you imagine standing next to a dude?
No.
So fucking smart that he created an atomic bomb,
like his inventions let gave birth of the atomic bomb and then you're standing
next to him why it blows up and he quotes that kind of shit.
Like he's happy about it.
He's not happy.
He wasn't happy at all.
He thought it was a terrible term.
Oh really?
Yeah.
Well a lot of these guys that are scientists that the real issue is,
and becoming a scientist,
you're,
you're pursuing knowledge.
You're pursuing the,
the,
the measurement of a,
of a,
of different experiments.
And,
and,
and you're,
you're trying to invent and create with technology,
but at a certain point in time,
you must know that if you continue down this path,
it's going to lead to insane amounts of people dying.
And in your mind,
it's a battle now,
but it,
cause it's because as a scientist,
as a,
a person is trying to achieve a goal,
you wanted to see if you can be the first person to do this.
You want to see if you can be the first person to split an atom inside of bomb
and lead.
To this incredible explosion of energy.
You want to be,
you want to do that,
but then you have to realize like,
wow,
if I do do that,
what the fuck am I really doing?
Like I'm,
I am,
I am the only way this can get done.
And then there's the argument,
well,
if you don't do it,
the Nazis are going to do it.
We have to do it argument.
That's what the argument was.
And so this guy was caught in there and he got there first and when he said
that,
you know,
that that became one of the creepiest quotes ever a attributed to anybody that's
responsible for anything like really monumental.
I had read that a lot of the scientists we got were Jews who left Nazi Germany
when they could get out.
I bet there was that too.
I'm sure there was that as well.
I mean,
that's Einstein.
Yeah.
Um,
but I think,
um,
the rocketry program in particular,
the NASA got a lot of,
uh,
they were,
they were still a lot of no Germans.
There were never Nazis.
It was a operation paperclip and meeting.
And how many of them were Nazis because their families were forced into that
because there were stuck there.
How many of were Nazis because they were really fucking psychopath creeps.
Who knows how many of them are actually responsible for murder?
I don't know.
I would love to know what he was saying though.
Cause you got to admit the guy was a riveting performer.
Hitler,
charismatic speaker.
I mean I thought,
do you ever see pictures of cruise chef?
Yes.
When he took his shoe off and bang,
Hey,
well Barry you fuck takes their shoe or for the Yulin?
Yeah.
Do you remember that fear that we had?
You know there was a oh yeah.
Of,
of being in a nuclear war with Russia.
Sure.
And it was on,
it was all the time.
We always felt it like that was a,
like in the eighties Dan was like,
especially because there was no internet back then,
we didn't know what the fuck was really going on.
Button.
The red,
the red phone picking it,
you know,
the president had that power.
But you would get your news like from,
you know,
either newspapers or the news shows that that's where you got your news.
I wonder if it ever came close to a nuclear war.
Well,
they say that,
uh,
the Bay of pigs,
they say the bay of Pigs,
it got pretty close.
Yeah.
Jerry here about their Russian sleep experiment that they did back in the,
uh,
I want to say the 1940s,
they wanted to keep five prisoners awake.
I meant the Cuban missile crisis,
not a bay of pigs,
but no,
what did they do?
They wanted to keep a five people wait,
they took five prisoners and they said like,
Hey,
uh,
we went to do some experiments on here and then we'll let you go.
So for a,
I think the first five days everyone was kind of,
you know,
fine,
and then it went from them like screaming like four hours at a time.
Like get me Outta here.
And like they had microphones in this,
like in this pen,
it was like,
you know,
a sealed kind of thing that had no windows and they had microphones.
So they could record everybody,
what they we talked about and stuff,
and they started going crazy.
They start screaming and everything and they were pumping this room,
fill,
there's some gas and test gas that they were trying to exclude.
It could keep soldiers up for 10 days at a time,
you know?
Uh,
and so then all the people started screaming.
Then they were quiet.
Then all the scientists were like,
I think the microphones aren't working when they're not making any noises at
all.
And so they go in there and uh,
they're all,
the people are just very calm.
They didn't want to leave anymore and stuff like that.
And then when they experiment,
it's over.
They wouldn't leave.
Like they were like fighting.
They,
they wanted to stay in this chamber.
They started,
people started like,
I guess people started like killing themselves because they didn't want to go,
like ripping their throats out and stuff like that.
Yeah.
And there's,
there's a video on youtube called,
what is the exact name of the Russian sleep experiment?
It's on,
it's on youtube and there's a bigger,
I think it's what the microphones recorded.
I'm,
I'm remembering this now,
but I think I might've in my own head incorporated it into that.
Do you remember that movie in the mouth of madness?
No.
It was a movie about a dude who was an author went fucking crazy.
And I think I attributed some of the aspects of his,
the,
the book had some weird power over people when they read the book that gets
sucked into this crazy world.
Like the world around them would change.
Really fascinating book.
Um,
I forget who wrote it.
I want to say it,
Stephen King,
but it's not the mouth of madness.
Yeah.
Uh,
there's a website called creepy Pasta Wiki or whatever,
just typing the Russian sleep experiment.
There's the whole story and he goes,
he breaks it down per hour.
And then like how,
how people just,
they started going crazy and,
and uh,
the,
uh,
the movie moving the mouth of mantises,
it's a John Carpenter movie.
Creepy ass movie.
It's a really good movie.
But,
uh,
I,
for some reason I incorporated that.
I guess that is like a real news story.
I incorporated that in my memory.
That's just goes to show you how like memories can be faulty as,
you know,
I incorporated that reality into a fake memory.
I guess some one of the people were hurt and they tried to give him an
anesthesia and the guy was like,
I must remain awake.
You know,
I must stay awake.
Like they,
whoa.
Uh,
yeah.
It's interesting though.
I read it if,
when you get a chance to read this whole thing,
are you sure this is not fiction?
I always thought it was real.
I've heard that there's people that questioned it,
uh,
because of the,
based on the youtube video,
because the youtube video is just the microphone.
So I think a lot of people are like,
and that's not real.
It's somebody just bullshitting,
you know?
Cause at one point they do start screaming and running around and stuff,
but I don't,
I don't,
I,
you know,
I never really researched it.
Uh,
it's something,
uh,
that I heard a long time ago.
Hmm.
But yeah,
I'm sure Internet will tell me if it's real or not.
So if it's on the Internet,
it's gotta be true.
Right?
Yeah.
I wanna I wanna I wanna find out if this is true.
Should I go to Snopes?
Is the Russian experiment sleep experiment?
True?
Huh?
Yeah.
I need to find this out because we can't keep,
it helps to make sure.
It's interesting though,
right?
Right.
This information p people get so aggro with correcting us.
Joe,
you're F you're spreading false knowledge.
I try so hard to get shit right.
When did get mad because I called the Hamp,
uh,
a cousin of marijuana.
[inaudible] says it's a cousin,
like everywhere online,
everywhere you read just Google cousin,
I think marijuana from him.
He be see has it?
It's a strain.
It's a different strain and it's the male of the species.
And I understand that.
And this guy was saying that I was spreading dish information.
It's like people like are like jumping up,
trying to catch you saying something wrong.
So when we have something like this,
yeah,
this is a way,
a nice way to say thanks folks.
Okay.
And if something's wrong,
say hey,
I think maybe there's a dispute about the definition of this.
Or Hey,
maybe you didn't know.
But even though everybody calls it a cousin,
it's something else.
Or Hey,
maybe,
you know,
just be nice folks.
Don't be all conti.
I have to stop with the disinformation.
Like you're doing it on purpose.
I have two friends that are lawyers and one of them always ends the argument by
going,
you're wrong.
Oh God.
So that shuts it all down.
Those that,
those guys are just so gross.
You can't,
you have a conversation,
you weak bitch,
have a conversation with someone who has a completely different point of view
from you and take it in.
That's why I don't talk politics because I've never seen anybody go at the end
of the political discussion.
You know what?
You got a good point.
I think I'm going to change my mind you,
there's an issue with a lot of men socially when it comes to arguing about
things and that issue is they're trying to win.
Yeah.
You know,
they're not just,
they're not comfortable with themselves enough to just be themselves.
Right.
They're trying to establish societal dominance is trying to establish a social
dominance.
I,
uh,
you know,
I have a friend,
okay.
Just
very nice person.
Um,
who has a husband the name over,
I won't,
who has a husband and a,
when I'm forced to interact with the sky,
it always becomes this weird thing where he tries to like brag about something
or,
yeah.
And it's,
it's this weird social thing.
Yeah.
And it might be like,
he'll try to crack a subtle joke at you or you know what,
but whatever it is,
it's this weird like uncomfortable,
like posturing thing that goes on.
Yeah.
And so when I'm,
I'm,
I'm around him,
I always like treat it like a research subject.
I was like,
wait,
what?
Did you know what,
what throws it off exactly.
You know,
what do we have to do to,
uh,
to get them to stop doing shit?
I just,
what should I do this time?
Should I just agree with them?
We'll go off for sure.
Amazing.
I say,
no,
you,
there are a really amazing guy.
Your wife is so fortunate,
you know,
change my life,
make them really uncomfortable.
We hang out together more.
Cause I think I can learn from you.
There's just something about you.
And what'd he do?
Progressive,
you know,
mock them or do you,
do you call them out on it?
I wouldn't call them out.
I think it's like the guy who was the Israel thing.
When I found out that he had posted this thing four times,
I called him up and I says,
you know,
really look forward to working with you again.
I understand you're coming in today.
If you need a,
I could send the car for her at the airport.
Or if I kept myself totally just being fucking evil,
I was,
you know,
but instead of like,
don't fuck you.
And then he's got that recorded.
It's like,
hey man,
thank you for doing that.
I appreciate it.
The exposure in Israel,
it's,
look,
it's indefensible.
The fact this guy wanted you to fly into a war zone is fucking nuts to tell some
jokey jokes,
guys,
an asshole.
You know,
he didn't like the fact that it would give us deposit back or whatever the fuck
went wrong.
But guess what,
Dude?
That's part of what goes on when you're dealing with shit in a war zone and it's
not the fucking entertainers fault.
They don't want to fly into a fucking war zone.
And the guy,
the writer apologized and he said,
we gotta be careful not to get comedians that they're skittish.
So in other words,
you know,
I'm sorry for what I said,
but these guys are pussies.
Skiddish skiddish yeah.
You know,
I don't think you used the word skittish when there's bombs,
he's skittish around bomb.
If there's actual bombs going off,
attacks from getting shot at,
is it a real war?
Oh,
it's a real war.
Ha.
And you're,
yeah,
I think you might be a little harsh.
Skiddish you'd judgemental cunt face.
Where does this guy live?
That shit.
Which one?
The guy who booked this shit.
Oh,
here.
He lives here.
Oh yeah.
It isn't live this and go over there.
He goes over,
but he doesn't live here.
How dare he?
Everyone's saying that Russian ships fake.
Yeah.
Probably 2009 it was just like this viral thing that went around a,
it's a fictional piece of work that appears to have started spreading a viral
fashion sometime in 2009 meanwhile,
we were just contributing information.
Brian.
Alicia,
that's good.
It's a nice story.
That was really creepy.
Creepy.
I remember from a while ago and I just,
you know,
remember reading and going,
huh,
that's crazy.
Just to
cool a p.
It's not even a hoax.
Apparently it was just a piece of fiction.
Yeah.
I liked this.
Prevented,
prevented all provigil.
Yeah,
I could feel it.
I feel like wide awake.
Yeah.
It's gonna.
It's gonna kick in even later pulses.
Your pulse elevated.
No,
we,
we learned about this shit from powerful Dave Asprey and powerful Tim Ferris.
It's an,
I just feel awake.
I will say no more.
Yeah,
but those guys can be,
if it works.
No,
that's the,
one of the cool things about having this podcast is that I get to hang out and
talk to all these like dudes way off the beaten path.
It would never get to communicate with like,
uh,
this Guy Dave Asprey who's just see,
I would guess you would call him like a human performance.
And he runs a,
a,
a tech company.
But on top of that,
he also like has this a website that he puts out all this information about
health and fitness and he does these brain hacking things and all,
you had to find him just,
um,
minimum line man met him through a communicating online,
you know,
people recommended has worked and they checked him out and we had the guy in
here.
He's a guy,
he's fucking super creepy genius.
It was one of those crazy,
um,
podcasts while like after it's over,
like you've got to go back with a piece of paper and write down shit and Google
things.
And yeah,
it was a crazy podcast.
I learned a lot of stuff and like how,
what are the odds of getting a chance to talk to a guy like that?
If you didn't have a podcast like this,
how would you get someone to sit down with you for three hours and talk about
shit?
Yeah.
You know,
I'm,
I'm always amazed by the mind.
And I used to teach school.
I taught fourth grade and I was amazed at how kids had different intelligence
and how,
like,
I remember I was really bad in math,
but I knew every,
the batting average of every,
the top 10 players in American national league without even thinking about it.
I knew that er,
they earned run average of the pictures and that incredible the way your mind
accepts things.
And then I was like fucking retarded in math.
Yeah.
I always loved that I could,
I knew like Marvin Hagler record.
Yeah.
You know,
I knew,
uh,
who we lost to,
what the decision was.
You know,
I knew a Durand's record,
you know,
I could read you back like how,
where,
where he had his first loss when he beat can be Canon to get the title to watch
that whole fight the other night.
Yeah,
I did.
I pack.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
That was a,
that was crazy.
It was crazy the way he walked into it.
Huh?
You can't let that and you can't make that instantaneous mistake.
And boxing you'd done?
I think he's got his attention very stretched as well.
There's a bunch of issues if pack.
Yeah,
I think,
I think one of the big issues is that he's like,
I don't think we can even wrap our heads around how famous that guy is.
Oh,
in the Philippines,
he's like a God,
he's gonna be president.
He could be president of the Philippines.
So there's that and he being a congressman over there,
well who knows what kind of crazy fucking pressure that guys under,
who knows?
I don't understand.
Then on top of that,
he's trying to chain train and then on top of that he's super famous,
so he's got to constantly do,
be doing media things,
constantly be doing interviews,
was constantly talking to people and then on top of that he has a family.
Like that's a lot of shit.
I don't,
I don't know.
I mean,
I don't know if you could really do that.
I think you could do it for a little while because you were so good at boxing to
begin with.
But I think he's at a point where his skills have started to slip because of the
fact that he's not putting the same amount of focus into it as it was because to
me the strategy and then on top of that he's had a lot of wars and he's had a
lot of crazy fights.
Yeah.
I mean he wasn't getting hit too much in other fights but man these,
these God mark has fights.
Mark has just has his number.
Some guys just have a,
I think he was winning up to that point.
Yes,
yes I did.
But he did get knocked down and he got knocked down with one punch and a,
that was the first time.
The first time he got knocked down you've got knocked down like in like was like
the fourth maybe and then he got knocked out in the sixth.
I understand him to go.
That's the cleanest punch I've ever seen.
Quick guy take like a guy that kind of lightening speed cause he really looked
into it flush,
flush it.
You couldn't hit a guy anyhow.
Perfect.
Any more.
Perfect mark has just drilled it down the middle.
Brilliant placement and when you see the impact of it,
we were,
we were watching it in a Dana White's dressing room and when you see the impact
of Paki Owl's head fly back,
you will like if they fell down face first and then you see him fall down face
first.
We all just like leapt up who?
I was like who saw that comment because Pacquiao was moving in on him like he
had heard.
Mark has got a little bit too cocky.
I looked up khaki cause I would love to hit somebody like that without fear of
getting hit back.
Well that's what I've always said.
Like people say like give,
what did you food man.
Which food in the mu first of all everybody wants to beat people up.
No one wants to fight.
Okay.
Everybody that says things like that,
you don't know what a fight is.
A fight as he gets to do that to you.
Too stupid,
but you know it's not a matter of who vote could keep gay as I just go in there
and kick his butt.
Then people who can also kick ass going to kick your ass.
You understand that,
right?
Like you,
you have to be ready for the craziest fucking competition known to man.
That's what professional fighter.
Yeah.
Trains is a fighter.
You can't just go kick ass.
Okay.
It does.
It was funny,
but people that talk about this guy,
he used to sell fucking throw it through a wall.
First of all,
when's the last time you were in a fight?
Second Grade.
You know what I mean?
Like these guys,
they talk about fighting all the time.
I'm fucking killed.
I'll break your fucking head.
You never did anything.
There's a fighting Koolaid,
a whole series of,
hey koolaid.
There's a whole series of dudes I've met throughout my life who have told me
that they can't lose because of their mentality.
It's this thing that guys will tell you,
this fucking guy,
it was a year ago,
I told me,
he goes,
I'll tell you why man.
If I dedicated myself to MMA,
if I dedicated myself,
I would dominate.
Cause Dude,
my mentality is I cannot lose getting hit here,
here and this nervous.
Yeah,
you can leave.
And I have to sit there when a guy says something like that and just non going,
yeah,
well good luck with that mentality but you don't understand my mentality.
I cannot lose when I get that in my head and just make sure you don't fight
anybody and they always invade your space when they're telling you this and
you're like okay.
Do you ever get people challenging you?
No,
no,
no.
I'm like super friendly,
you know,
very standoffish at all am I know you're great with paypal.
But if uh,
if someone like,
like those kind of guys,
if you know,
if you challenged them,
if you want to like getting in an altercation with a dude,
you can say something and they will probably hit you.
Yeah.
There's a lot of people that are just running around looking for someone to hit.
I told you that ray man,
see any story,
right?
What?
What happened?
He came to see me at the Improv with his wife and his kids and then when I got
off he came out to talk to me and this guy comes up and
he goes,
hey ray,
boom,
boom man.
Sini and it's great,
you know,
it gets all excited.
He goes,
hey ray,
can you hit me?
And he goes,
why?
I go,
look man.
He goes,
yeah,
I want to see what it feels like to get hit by professional box.
It just like hit me and you know,
I gotta look man,
he can't hit and raise the nicest fucking guy and where he can't hit you.
Right?
And the guy goes,
oh,
come on.
He goes,
all right,
well can I hit you?
Then I go,
well you get the fuck out of here.
Can I hit you then what the fuck?
I know.
Can I hit you then?
Can I give you a shot just to show you how strong I am?
I'm just on the arm.
I had a guy asked me if he could carry me once.
I think it would carry me.
Okay.
You inside?
He put his jacket down over the puddle.
He take a picture with me.
He wanted to hold me when that's how he said it too.
He's like,
no the fuck is wrong with you man.
Big giant dude.
He was this big,
he looked like it was a native American long hair,
long dark hair.
Scary as fuck.
Juicy fruit cause he had no problem with that guy.
Take a while.
Can I carry you?
Come on.
Crazy like it.
Probably like six,
eight six,
nine big giant dude.
Wanted to pick people up and pictures
does thing.
Strange Fetish but understandable.
Well you know when that's
got,
you know it's a funny thing when people like,
you know,
they're like super proud of like a physical attribute that there were,
sort of born with like being like really crazy tall,
tall.
I am.
I'm just three fucking tall being tall and all and like,
it's a strange thing.
You know,
I spent,
I guess suspect guys,
a big decks,
have that tail happy.
We do happy that they got a big Dick.
But listen man,
you could have easily been born with a micro Dick's that you laugh out online.
Back to didn't ask for that deck and you didn't ask for your Dick.
You got lucky.
What is that you're showing in the corner?
People are saying that you are,
uh,
undercover Russian spy or something like that.
How's that?
So I'm showing the KGB logo,
why they stay undercover west,
the fucking spine
storage show.
Yeah.
It's fun to watch live feedback.
Joe Doesn't like it.
Well,
the problem is they'll,
they will entertain your thoughts with a lot of negative shit.
Yeah.
You know,
and you,
you're inviting.
I mean,
every now and then it might be fun,
but you were inviting too many,
uh,
too many options.
People really think you're arrest alien or,
or all that shit.
Like they're really,
people believe that you're part of the,
yeah,
the Illuminati.
I'm sure there's some,
look,
there's a lot of people that are what you call paranoid schizophrenia x and
that's legit.
And that's not like a small percentage of our population.
You know,
there's like,
I know several,
I know,
I know many people that have like legit mental illnesses.
I think it's super common.
Yeah.
So if you're a person with a legit mental illness and you know,
you see someone on television,
you can get completely convinced that they're involved in some sort of civic
society to hold you down.
I know a dude who's losing his mind,
but that one dude we know who was losing his mind thinks that everybody's
working for the fucking CIA.
People being mind controlled and shit.
Like,
what are you like,
stop,
settle the fuck down.
It's much,
there's much less conspiracy afoot than people would like to see fit there.
Then people would like to,
uh,
like to believe.
Have you ever been contacted by any of these groups?
Like,
like Scientologists are Illuminati
ontology.
They seem to,
they have a lot of money and then they protect their people.
Well,
we have to rework some of your rules,
but I think we'll be fine.
Yeah.
But I guess if you,
not saying that religion did,
they,
did they believe in God or they believe they're a group about assets.
They're very successful.
If you look at what Scientology has done,
they're,
they're amazing at making money and it managing their business,
their business of Scientology and amazing at acquiring really expensive real
estate.
I think they're like a big real estate holder in Los Angeles.
They own like some really big fucking buildings,
a lot of like really expensive stuff.
So they're smart.
That was all on Hubbard,
right?
Yeah.
Well he's the guy who started it has been dead for a long time.
Do they think that,
uh,
did they believe in a god or they believe their God,
they believe aliens.
They believe some crazy shit written by l Ron Hubbard.
That's what's really weird about it.
It's like they believe some,
it seems to me that some people just need a structure that needs some stuff that
tells them all the answers.
Every question that they have is answered,
whether it logical or not.
Some people just need that base covered and they'll take that base from time
tology of tea.
They'll take that base from Buddhism or they'll take that base from
Christianity,
they'll take that base from whoever gets there first.
Whoever gets there first,
whoever's in the right position who resonates with them the most,
they'll accept that.
And for something like Scientology,
one of the good things about Scientology as opposed to a lot of the other
religions is there's a lot of like pretty interesting principles that they,
that they masked with in terms of managing your consciousness in terms of
positive thinking and accepting um,
uh,
positive things in your life and acting change.
Like then there's like a lot of like,
uh,
like that's why dianetics were so successful.
Like dianetics when they sold it on TV,
you didn't know that you were becoming a part of some sort of crazy religious
cult.
The thought that you were buying a self help book.
And uh,
I bought a bunch of self help books,
man.
I bought Tony Robbins Shit.
I listened to his books on tape.
Yeah.
When I was a,
when I was poor as fuck,
living in revere.
Um,
I used to live in cities.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
I was well struggling comedian,
I was listening to Anthony Robbins tapes and just thinking about like how to
make things happen.
Like he's like really good motivator,
you know,
and the,
the dianetics thing,
I thought it was this very similar,
that's what I thought it was.
And then when I got it,
when I,
um,
when I got the book they sent me invitations to go to like the Scientology
center and all this different Shit.
They sent me them almost every month.
They were relentless for years.
Like if you are lost,
they reach out and they just get you,
it's like this is pre internet.
Okay.
Cause this is like 1994.
So it was fascinating to me because I didn't understand what it was.
I didn't,
we had no internet.
Okay.
We'll wrap your head around that.
People.
So when I,
if someone asked me what Scientology was,
I had to like literally go to a store.
I had a bio book,
I had read it myself.
So in reading this dianetics book and then getting all these emails from these
males,
actual physical mail sent to my mailbox from this group,
I was like,
what the fuck is this?
So then it piqued my curiosity and then I really looked into when I was like,
wow,
this is a,
this is amazing.
This is a cult and this is ever going to get any of that.
No,
no.
I never went to like a meeting or anything,
but I did sit down with a dude and he did that a stress test thing on me.
What they did.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
But that was way later.
That was like a couple of years ago.
Well,
you definitely needed,
it.
Didn't like the outcome of that test was like,
you need to become a scientologist.
It was pretty,
pretty clear.
Um,
it was,
it's the most ridiculous device ever.
Um,
I'm sitting there and I don't think,
I wish that we had,
um,
uh,
Kara Santa Maria on who she could explain us the science behind it and how
woefully lacking it is and real science.
But it gives,
you really does.
But anyway,
um,
this,
they would sit down with you and you hold on to this e meter and even ask you
questions.
And I don't remember the nature of the questions,
but I just remember it being so ridiculous.
And I remember asking like,
how many different things can affect this?
You know,
what about intent does intent if effect it,
what if I get angry?
Does that affect it?
So then I tried to just like think of answers like in a fucked up way.
So like really raised my craziness up.
Oh No,
I,
I I I I'm not exactly sure cause it was really high when I did this.
Um,
but so it wasn't that long ago.
It wasn't,
it was a couple years ago.
It was,
um,
I was filming,
game show in my head.
Okay.
We were down there cause so that was,
uh,
that was pre before fear factor came out.
So it was a couple of years ago,
at least three years ago.
Anyway,
point being,
I'm standing there with these fucking tin cans and my hands,
like holding onto this thing and this guy who is reading out of this book like a
Prozac Zombie,
I mean,
he's like,
he's,
he's a weird,
disconnected dude and he's reading me these things.
He definitely doesn't know who I am.
Uh,
you know,
he's never watched fear factor or anything before he's,
he was 100%.
Like,
he,
uh,
asked me my name a couple of times.
He forgot it.
He had to ask me it again.
But the,
um,
the way he was like taking me through.
Do you feel,
uh,
what,
how do you feel when you feel about your childhood?
Hmm.
I'm like,
great.
It's pretty good.
Good childhood.
I'm here.
I'm healthy.
Okay.
How do you feel about your education?
Like if you're asking me these weird questions when I'm holding onto the floor,
I don't know.
I don't understand it.
And they were trying to like show that you have a certain amount of stress in
your life and what they would recommend is that you look into dianetics and then
you look into dianetics and then boom,
you're,
you're a scientologist.
And what,
you know,
Scientology can too for a lot of people is provide them with a framework,
provide them with like a scaffolding.
It gives him like a way to like move forward and that,
that that's legit for everybody.
For what it's Christianity or anything.
When you give someone a framework,
sometimes it just looked,
all they need is a step by step instruction of how to get through life or how to
move through,
you know,
to the next stage how to,
how to go get a job,
how to get their shit together.
Like people need like instructional,
even even wack ones,
you know,
he's in Wac,
ones that have aliens in them and like what?
All that other stuff,
the [inaudible] and the volcanoes and what does the story do?
Anything that we can play a quick south park like,
yeah,
let's do that.
Let's do that.
Because this is the why.
Why fuck around when the masters already nailed it.
Okay.
Hold on.
Let me get this,
get this.
I can tell you what stresses you Joe.
What the reason.
Lack of integrity.
Yeah.
Anything.
He's stealing material people that bullshit.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
Let's,
let's listen to this.
Let's see if we can,
there was a reason for people getting sab
75 billion years ago.
Back then,
that was a galactic federation,
which was ruled over by the Lord Walk,
walk,
walk.
Galaxy was overpopulated and so he rounded up the hop as aliens from all
different plans and the hospitals.
The graphic it says,
this is what Scientology was actually right,
believe which looked like DC Hayes except the croc cruisers.
They took the frozen alien bodies to harm and dump them into the volcanoes of
Hawaii.
The aliens were no longer have chosen
the souls of those aliens.
However they've gone and all bloated up towards the sky.
But the evil Lord Zino had repaired for this Paul Paul Walker shows to return.
And so we built giant full catchers in the sky,
the rain watching to see what he wishes he knew about all the phones were forced
to watch days of brainwashing material.
What's trick them into believing a false reality.
Vito,
good release behavior,
which roamed the earth.
English reading the fog of confusion at the dawn of Man.
The is finally found bodies which you can grab onto.
They attached themselves.
All man con is still to this day talking all our fears.
Yeah.
That's where our fears,
our confusions in our problems come from,
from the Seatons were so fucking smart,
aren't they?
Oh,
those guys
are the best.
I love south firing.
Have you ever met those guys?
You Know Eric laughing?
Have,
do they,
have you ever been to the laugh factory or do they come in there and what's the
guy's name?
Trey Parker and Matt Stone.
Trey Parker.
I met somewhere along the line.
Oh that's cool.
But I think he was producing a long time ago,
maybe on Fox or something.
They're writing.
So you used to open up for share.
Did you ever mess around with shared?
Did you ever get a part of that,
that everyone like mess around with share?
You mean like sexually?
Yeah.
Or Know
No.
Wear her outfit with the,
but I remember one night we were working at the Mirage and I would,
you know,
and when we work in like casinos,
we would see each other like I don't have an arena or there'd be a break after
it,
you know,
so I would never see her cause she'd be putting on one over wigs and her
eyelashes,
Shit.
And she goes to me,
uh,
as we're walking,
we're walking by and she goes,
I can't believe you did a just over a hedge joke,
my grandmothers here.
I said,
I can't believe that your grandfather gets to see your ass.
Later on that night were downstairs
party in her room and her grandmother says like,
almost like it was a sitcom.
She goes,
I love that bit you did about the hedge.
All right.
She goes,
you know what the fuck?
She was cool.
Very cool.
You know,
it's so weird how people are,
like friend of mine is working with her,
they're doing a gig in Russia soon and she,
you know,
I mean she's very fucking talented,
obviously she accomplished whether you like her or not and she's insecure about
her voice,
you know,
and I'm,
I'm,
I'm fuck,
I suck,
but I love to sing.
I'm singing with him or all my fucking arm.
Then it's secure.
I don't,
but of course she's famous,
you know,
as a singer.
But it's just so weird how people can be insecure and we know this from any part
of show business,
you know,
the needy comedian would you think?
Yeah.
It's the worst and unfortunately this is a lot of us that I really liked it or
like that they want to come up and see is this good?
Is this okay?
Yeah.
Like,
come on man.
Get out of here with that shit.
Go up there dude.
It's funny because the way we do stand up,
all of us together,
it's kind of the same way when we all get together.
We have these shows,
whether it's a are your Dunkin or or Joey or whatever.
We're just hanging out and then one of us will go on stage,
meaning we,
you've done these shows with us.
Of course another one would go onstage,
but every now and then we'll bring someone new into the mix and then they're
like I said,
he could match it up with this,
which I did.
What are you doing?
Go Up.
Go up there.
Come on man.
Joey was both of them.
Both of them were on that show list and I did.
They left I think before you came in.
I just,
I met Ari upstairs.
They were both,
they're both fucking really funny,
but Joey was fucking high as it could.
I can't.
His eyes were like clothes.
There's I'm so fucking item and they almost fell.
I tell you,
it must fell off to big boy.
Big Boy.
That's not good.
If he falls off that stage,
that's not a fall backwards near the way.
He's good,
but he would have killed the shingles up front.
He can.
You can break things.
I wish I was.
I was watching those
when you were doing some of those bits and said they couldn't fucking help but
laugh,
you know when you did the the the last bit,
but you know.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
They,
I loved watching him.
I love watching people who can't help laugh even though they think I've seen
people shake their head and laugh.
I go,
no,
you can't disapprove and left 11 when you're out with coworkers and because you
don't want those other ladies in your office to how you know,
like you're all on the corporate ladder together.
You don't want them to have a turn it on.
Yeah.
We went there and you see this one every fucking blow job jokes.
She's laughing her ass off.
But before you came in I asked him something that you really shouldn't ask
women.
We shouldn't ask him.
I said,
which one are you?
Which one of you ladies do you think is the hottest and also the at least hot.
And then one of them was their boss and go leave her out of it.
Then she's the boss.
But just like,
I mean,
obviously one of you is in a different league than the others.
I could,
I could see and they were like fucking laughing and at least one of them is
thinking,
I wonder if it's me,
you know?
Wow.
That's funny.
Yeah.
I think they liked you tomorrow.
I love fucking with people.
I love interacting.
Yeah,
we're,
we're doing a show,
Joan,
if you ever want to come in,
I don't want to be a fucking a plugged machine,
but it's going to be called busting balls with dom.
Rarer and,
and we encourage interaction with the crowd and how they say,
no talking during the show.
I want you to fucking talk.
I want you to break balls then we have,
yeah.
And then we'll,
we'll have a,
uh,
also an interview and we can bust each other's balls where we can be fucking
goofy,
you know,
so it's essentially not heckling because you're actually encouraging the
interaction.
It's not heckling,
you know,
it's not like a regular comedy show.
No,
that's second.
It's going to confuse the shit out of your regular comedy club people.
But I'll say it at the beginning,
you know,
but then they're gonna want,
they're gonna want that kind of Damo rarer action.
I'm gonna.
I don't want that,
that,
that spontaneous shit.
I don't mind.
You don't mind.
You know,
I don't like when it bits get interrupted.
I don't mind talking to people.
I love talking to you don't get interrupted.
People have to,
you give sometimes.
Sometimes you do.
You know this drunk man drops for a while.
That's part of our business and they,
and they also want to like have an interaction with you.
You ever have people call out your bits?
Like you're not doing enough that,
yeah,
they'll say do that,
but you know,
can't fuck.
It's really hard to do a bit when someone asks,
you can do it cause it's so and spontaneous.
It's also really hard to do a bit when you know that they already know it.
Yeah.
It's like,
you know,
it's not not the same as a song.
It's weird because it was for dice.
Right.
You know when dice was at his peak.
That's one of the things is everybody would like say the joke with them.
What's in the bowl.
You can also his audiences.
God lives in fear was that I am a part of,
I was probably in the audience.
I want to see dice in Vegas.
I had a good old time.
He tried to bad mouth me on the show.
No,
he didn't pay it and you were covering for me,
you and Eleanor.
I hear.
I hear things.
Listen,
you guys kind of hug it out.
Hug it out as
too old school gangsters.
Dice,
dice friends at one time.
Yeah,
I know you were.
Yeah.
He's a good guy.
I like him.
He's not a good guy.
Good guy to me.
He's a good guy to you.
He's not a good guy.
I'm a good guy.
You're a great guy.
I'm good.
You're a great,
if I had to choose between the two of you,
take you.
Me Too.
You guys are all getting in trouble now you guys.
I do.
I just wished the deicing died.
Let's dom,
dom.
I to be my friend,
my good friend since like 1990 I love dice.
I'm a fuge fan of his.
I grew up being inspired by like dice,
but I liked him better.
I'm not just saying that,
but it just gets done.
Dom is my very good friend.
We,
we'd diamond,
I play pool every week.
I can't go without dom said the sex have sex with dom or Andy.
Andy Roddick.
Andrew dice clay.
Yeah.
Oh,
I would dice as much harder than me.
Beautiful guys.
Softer and club.
More of a challenge.
The whole dice down.
Yeah.
I think it'd be cleaner.
That's what you could shoot as well.
For me.
It's gotta be some support in it.
I want to be fucking that dude.
It's got to be a bit of a struggle.
I think I couldn't do it.
I couldn't get a hard on seeing the hairy ass.
You say that,
but what if that became your thing?
Well,
how's it going to become my thing?
You know,
if there's one skyrocket orgasm,
because apparently a big dude like that can really clench down on his ass cheeks
and anybody getting hungry.
And when you score it,
you squirt like you've never scored it before and then you just make a decision.
Okay,
you should write poetry month.
You've got away with words,
Labelle fuck game.
You know,
I've tried,
I tried to get over to Karma bit.
It's tough for me with the Italian thing what him and I just hold grudges,
you know?
Yeah.
But I only have three.
There's only three comedians I hate.
Who are the other two?
Uh,
Craig Shoemaker and Bobby Collins.
Wow.
I can't believe you got that out of me.
I don't know.
Shoemaker.
I've only met him once.
Fucking asshole.
What's wrong with shoemaker?
Uh,
he's just a bragging cunt and I said it with all due respect,
Joe.
He's just a,
you know.
All right.
I'll give you an example.
Okay.
I'm trying to clean up my Karma,
right?
A couple of years ago they said,
do you mind if,
um,
you know,
I draw well in Atlantic city,
so I'm going to do the regatta.
And they said he might've shoemaker up was for you.
Now he was getting $7,500 to open.
So,
you know,
I was getting good money,
right?
So I said,
you know what?
Fuck it.
Go clean up the Karma.
Let them open.
Right?
That's 45 minutes instead of 25 to fuck me.
And you know what he said at the end,
he goes,
I'll never work with you again.
And I said,
why is that?
And I'm thinking,
you don't got a chance to work with me again.
He goes,
because I can't believe you could follow me.
What a fucking ego.
What a jerk.
He was upset.
He was upset because I him,
he thought he buried me.
So was it like a Jew?
Was he like sort of jokingly,
uh,
jokingly praising,
you know,
he's just such a deck.
He wasn't joking at all.
He just really thought nobody could follow him cause he got a standing ovation.
So I walked out,
I got like a fucking guy up for me.
It got a standing ovation when I'm not going,
what am I supposed to fly around the room?
You know,
I mean,
and then,
but they were there to see me.
So,
you know,
it was,
it was not hard.
Really hard to bury someone when people are there to see you.
I know he was just,
and I didn't even get laid into him.
Like what an ancillary was telling him about the time.
Well,
I mean,
imagine just doing 20 minutes over when you're opening for somebody.
Just money and fucking run.
Yeah.
Why did he do that to Jack Him?
No,
because I just didn't want to communicate with him.
I didn't want to fucking have a talk out with them and because I don't want to
be friends with them.
Right.
So that was it.
You were trying to clean up your Karma and I blow it and then I blow Bobby
Collins at fucking Dick face.
Do you know him?
You know him,
Bobby Collins Shit.
I don't know him very well.
I know you never show.
He's the exact,
yeah,
I said to you,
he doesn't have a fucking honest bone.
His body,
so fucking phony.
He's the kind of guy,
he'll go,
this guy Frankie who used to work at the comedy connection.
Frankie Baby,
look at you lost weight.
Frankie goes,
damn,
I look like I'm going to fucking explode.
I gained the a hundred pants.
I saw this phony fuck.
But that's the kind of guy he was.
So he demanded to,
uh,
we were working together at Staten Island and I don't give a fuck about going on
first.
I don't give a fuck.
I just want to get the money,
have a good time,
get out of there.
And I was supposed to headline this show and it said it in the contract.
So the Bobby Collins was throwing a fit about,
he's throwing a fit about who was going to close the show to watch it.
Pixie from Paul.
I'm looking at phony fucking smiling.
Hi Guys.
I'm a white boon.
So anyway,
he,
uh,
he calls up,
he wants to close,
cause he went to sell merchandise after the show.
So the producer calls me,
they say quo Donald,
he's a good guy.
Oh fucking,
I don't care.
So she calls me and she goes,
you know,
do you mind if he closes?
I go,
look,
I'm a headliner.
I headline that.
You see what it says in the contract?
She goes,
oh,
I understand.
You're right.
I go,
I don't give a fuck.
I'm kidding you.
I said,
I'll do a meet and greet at the beginning and then get out of there.
I don't care if they're going to pay me,
I'll do my best.
Anyway,
after that month later,
Mike Ivy,
my friend,
my black friend from Mississippi,
Tove Lo,
you know Nikki,
I love you brother.
And he goes,
uh,
Nikki,
all God asks you a question where you opened them for Bobby Collins and Staten
Island.
I'm like,
what do you think?
Right?
So he goes,
no.
I said,
well,
it's not even worth talking about is anyway.
I see Bobby at the common struggle.
Bobby,
you're fucking pathetic.
Dommy baby.
I see you.
Just pathetic.
And then I walked away and I was it.
So that,
that's so much for cleaning up my Karma.
This isn't on the air,
is it?
I don't think so.
Okay.
The cons are closed a spring 2007 CFA season,
the laughter arts festival.
What does that,
what does the CFA
college of Staten Island,
that's where you guys were.
Oh,
that's funny.
It's great.
You can look at Schiller.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well I'm sorry you had those bad experiences with those two guys.
But I mean I bet your ironed it out by just out in them on the road.
You never had the guys just come up to you like for some things you've said on
podcasts yet,
cause you,
you've been very outspoken with like,
you know,
I'm on the edge,
but I love most people,
very honest guy.
If you tell me,
you know that someone's been a con to you,
I always believe you.
Yeah.
I mean I would never,
I tried to like patch things up and then I was wrong.
I was right.
I wish I was wrong,
you know what I mean?
I wished that I,
it was worked and,
but it didn't work out at me.
You know how many guys and these guys,
Oh,
do we do the thing about Louis C k the shitty?
No,
you started it.
I was just talking about people I love,
I don't know what happened.
You know,
you and Louie and,
uh,
Bill Berg,
best best comics in the world.
Fucking that Taj and Louis used to come into Montreal and uh,
okay,
so he'd be in the audience and the character was [inaudible] ship balls.
That's the grossest,
and so I'd be hosting the show.
I go,
excuse me,
I think we've got a celebrity in the audience.
And he put his hand over his head and go,
no,
I go,
is that you conti?
Is that you?
And he goes,
I said,
Connie Mcshane,
pause everybody.
Right everybody.
Yay.
Cause we had plants all over the room and then he kinda,
he happens to have a guitar by a seat.
I go,
Connie,
how about a song?
No,
I can't play it.
Con t con t the whole crowds go and then he comes up and does his fucking salt.
Oh,
he used to cry laughing.
That's Alaria.
I never seen Louie happier.
He loved doing the character Cunty Mc Shit.
I Dunno if we had a middle name.
You know,
I,
I've said this before,
I'm gonna say it again,
but Stan Hope said this and I never agreed with him more.
He goes,
I could quit doing comedy,
but I couldn't,
couldn't quit hanging out with standups.
Yeah.
So just to have that kind of experience,
be able to tell that story.
Oh yeah.
It's fucking fun.
That's actually your job.
That's what you do for work.
I do.
For a living.
Yeah.
I mean what we did last night,
that's,
that was our job.
We,
dom and I worked together last night at the laugh factory.
Right.
We worked work and we're hanging out.
Just laughing.
And I remember so hosted some shows thinking this is what I do.
I was,
there's one of you ever hear about the guy who sticks to Roman candle up his ass
and,
and they light it and then it flares and they play any works.
It's random too.
There's no business like show business.
Really?
Yeah.
Can you look him up?
You got to see this as one of the funniest fucking thing.
Lights of Roman [inaudible] sticks it in his hair.
Oh my God.
He pulls large pieces of furniture out of his ass.
Remember that from a Jerky boys.
I'm also known,
so I'll have to,
dude,
I listen to some jerky boys the other day and was fucking hilarious.
I forgot how funny the shit was.
How do those guys stopped doing that?
What happened there was so good because the rules change with telephone calls
and people remember that.
Then they changed it where you can only do it in Vegas.
You can only do it in Nevada.
Like make prank calls cause all kinds of legal shit.
Plus people started getting,
getting onto it because they,
you know,
they're becoming famous.
That's why I wonder what the impractical jokers you ever see that show?
Uh,
I haven't seen it.
Check it out.
It's really good.
Funny.
Yeah.
Excellent.
Did you hear about those practical jokers that committed suicide in Australia?
What,
what happened?
Do you know?
Yeah,
so there was a hospital,
the WHO,
who is there or the queen or the princess or what's the duchess,
the duchess,
whatever.
All right.
Some royalty was there.
And so,
uh,
this radio station had this prank where they're going to act like the,
the mom.
So I guess the Queen,
uh,
and they were controlled.
And so they operate or like they called up and they were like,
oh no,
I would like to speak to my daughter,
I don't eat or whatever.
And the operator just let her through like,
Oh yes,
one second please.
Instead of like,
you know,
like how do I know this is the right person?
And stuff like that.
And then,
uh,
they did this prank on the radio station and I guess as you know,
because of the royal keeps trade crown and she killed herself,
had herself,
if my,
my,
my granddaughter Kate is my grand daughter,
Kate there please,
or she wasn't 30 said they like immediately the people on the phone really did
immediately give up information about her condition.
Like they started just rattling off the information.
They didn't like double check at all.
They weren't even remotely suspicious.
Talk about fucking up your day though.
Huh?
I mean,
everybody,
everybody loses.
Yeah,
the girl's dead.
The,
the,
the hospital security's a question now.
And these people lose their jobs.
They just meant to get a laugh.
Yeah.
Morrissey is really interesting.
You know,
Marcy,
the the singer,
he's blaming the,
um,
he's blaming Kate Middleton for the death cause he's saying the arrogance of the
British royals is staggering and that's why we're,
uh,
and why it's allowed.
I really don't know.
So He's,
he's saying that
the recent story about the nurse killing herself,
there's no blame placed on Kate Middleton who was at the hospital for as far as
I can see.
No reason.
She feels no shame about the death of this woman.
She's saying nothing about the death of this poor woman.
Boy.
Morrissey needs a fucking hug.
What a depressed guy.
What does that mean?
How does he know what another person feels?
How can he say like,
she feels nothing.
How,
how can you,
how can you really say that?
Um,
what is,
what is someone say when someone commits suicide over a prank?
Like that?
Yeah,
but you can't say she feels no shame.
She's saying nothing.
How did,
does she,
is she supposed to say something publicly about that?
I mean,
what,
what obligations do you have to,
she has,
yeah,
she has nothing to do with it.
What obligations does she have to comment on something that's obviously a
horrific thing.
And you know,
to blame her,
that's so ridiculous.
Silly Morrissey,
the idea of the royal family is crazy though,
that the fact that you could give a fuck,
CNN had it on,
it was the,
the problems in Gaza.
Okay.
And CNN was talking about the dangers of Gaza showed like some night vision with
a bomb going off and shit like that.
And then they said,
and you know,
Royal Kate,
whatever the fuck her name is,
is pregnant,
there will be another baby baby.
But you know,
next to it.
Yeah,
I know.
It's,
and it stands cause itself.
It's crazy.
Joe.
I was in uh,
Canada and when the Queen Mother died at 102 I had a bit about her,
you know,
about it,
like she looked 101,
this whole thing she got on the treadmill thing.
But uh,
I,
when I did it in Montreal,
it got an applause.
It's interesting how people react to royalty.
When I did it in Ottawa,
which is more mixed Montreals mostly French and a French and English,
but they're not,
they're not under the auspices of the crown by any stretch.
Ottawa,
it a little bit,
you know,
laugh,
mild applause,
Toronto and nothing.
Nothing.
Not a fucking sound.
Yeah,
it did.
An American would have the arrogance to come up and do something against the
Queen and that funny,
like the same fucking job,
just a couple of hundred miles
west boom.
Now it's very weird when you see people that are really like it taken into the
royal family thing.
The oils like leave the royals,
they live their lives that they read about them,
like as if their thoughts are more,
more important.
And yeah,
I was,
I'm making fun of the Queen when I was,
uh,
when I was in England one time,
I forgot which town were around,
but it wasn't like London,
London.
They probably would have laughed their asses off,
but these people were like,
oh yeah,
you gotta Watch Manchester.
While I don't remember what town it was.
It wasn't Manchester.
Maybe it was new castle,
maybe was Newcastle.
Anyway,
wherever I was,
um,
I had this,
uh,
this whole bit about how people like try to pretend that like that this queen,
this woman was like really like a queen.
Like you know that Princess Diana really was actually a princess.
Like,
no,
that's just a person.
Like,
and she's a woman who didn't even have a job and you know,
and,
and she tried,
she had a woman with children who tried to kill herself like three times,
you know,
and I'm like,
how many people would be in that same position and Leno and,
and be incredibly fortunate and feel so happy that they have all this money.
How many poor people would love to be married?
Wealth?
And she was like,
oh no,
the tiers code,
the crumpets a stale,
where's the razor?
I cannot possibly go on the tabloids showed you a photo of my backside quickly
drained the pool that will die from the roof.
This is horrid.
Horrid.
Life cannot go on.
And I have like a whole series of those fucking things and they didn't know how
to react.
Oh yeah,
they started,
they still like,
you could see people like,
oh,
oh that's cause you're American too.
But they got,
they went with it.
They went with it.
Eventually,
eventually I beat,
I beat them down with it cause it's just like,
come on.
It sucks when everybody dies.
It's like this is not a,
you don't need royals.
You don't need the ancestors of the people who suppressed your ancestors and
give them some special favors.
This is crazy.
You know,
that's like,
but they're holding on to that shit somehow or another.
And they've gone from being these,
uh,
these horrible dictators,
which they used to be to these weird sort of benevolent people wave and hold
some strange position of,
of,
of like a,
a like a social example,
you know,
example of the perfect etiquette,
the perfect behavior.
Yeah.
I mean at least the pope was elected.
Not that,
you know,
not that his wealth that shouldn't be in question two,
but they were just born into it.
It's craziness.
And then marrying into it is even more hilarious.
They're over such as prejudice.
It's fucking nuts.
And everybody's following it.
I mean it's like so dumb.
Who was the one that gave up the crown because he,
he,
he wanted to marry somebody remembered that one of the guys gave up the crown.
Can you imagine how fucking hot that bed to give up the fucking cram?
Yeah.
Well I bet in England like being a royal is,
what do you think it's better though?
England or like in like Saudi Arabia or something like that and like a Middle
Eastern country and uh,
you say that though,
but those Saudi Arabian guys rocket way better.
Yeah.
They,
the Middle Eastern guys,
they rock it the right way when they want to go balls out.
Yeah,
they do it.
I would pay girls hundreds of thousands of dollars to be sex slaves and then
they have definitely,
cause you're not judged as much.
Nobody is rocking it.
Like those young chic dudes that have those like,
like that one guy,
the sultan of Brunei,
that guy,
he's the guy that has like the famous parties where he will fly out like the
hottest women.
Apparently it was like a dirty secret for the longest time.
Pre-Internet.
He would get like the all the hottest penthouse paths actresses and shit that
like,
you know,
weren't doing so well because you could go over there and you could make like an
insect.
I'll give her a call and I'm not joking.
Yeah.
And I got a Gig with those guys and they sent me a watch.
There was worth like 20 grand.
It's like ridiculous.
And they were asking me about Italian batch were just so fucking funny from
Saudis that they knew like Joey bag of donuts.
That's fun.
It's old shit.
That's hilarious.
There's those guys have so much money that this guy,
the salt,
no Brunei apparently has a disco in his house,
makes his own discount,
which is beautiful.
Unbelievably lavishly appointed disco gold gilded work on the ceiling and
magnificent and just filled with tens.
She's tens everywhere and this guy just goes out there and slides amongst them.
It has a cocktail mingles mixes with the next group or they're all trying to
impress him and they're all trying to compete.
And it was him and a few of his friends,
I guess.
I think it just fucking bang them.
Just walk every night and every night he's fishing in this stock pond.
I mean,
it's really the,
nobody's ever been such a baller because he's not,
he's not actually enslaving anybody.
He's paying them significant amounts of money.
Okay?
He's not corrupting their morals.
They're willing to do this.
Okay.
There's nothing wrong with the exchange because the amount of money to make an
is really fucking staggering.
But when you really stop and think about like how many guys have ever done it
like that?
The Sultan of Brunei is probably doing it the nicest.
Wherever everybody else who did it,
they did it with armies.
You know,
every,
every other guy that's like lived like that,
they did it with swords and you know,
conquering towns and keeping chicks in cages and shit.
This guy just pays him stupid amounts of money based on oil money.
Wow.
That sounds like fun.
I mean,
I think pre Prince Charles is kind of sad because he's at the point now where
he's like,
he loves his mother,
but you know,
mom,
could you die already?
So it can be King Charles to be king before I'm 70 do you know if she lives to a
hundred you know what the fuck's going to happen to him?
Yeah.
She might outlive live him.
Yeah,
it's possible.
Oh sure.
You know who's under more stress?
No,
she's probably just nice and slow all day.
He's running around doing shit,
trying to fucking make ends meet.
Trying to put food on the table.
Dot.
My rarer.
They're poor prince.
What does that guy do all day?
[inaudible] you know,
she still play snooker.
Did you look something up?
Yeah,
but holes and fireworks and I just got really lost and I found an old article
from 91 where you were with Ellen doing comedy and,
and Miami or something like that.
Do you ever Bang her
Ellen degeneres?
Yeah.
Oh,
Hey,
talk to this week.
Sorry.
I gotta take a leak.
No,
I never bagged down now.
I Love Ellen.
I know.
No,
I worked with her,
uh,
that worked at her in Miami too.
If it's something,
it looks like it was 91 that you worked with her.
I know I worked with her.
Would see I need to Atlantic city 92 for Hbo,
one night stand maybe.
Oh,
okay.
She's,
I didn't remember it all and do it.
I mean,
I know she did one,
but I didn't know she did it,
uh,
the same night as me.
Maybe she did,
but a great standup.
Ellen.
Yeah.
And did you ever know anyone that dated her or was she always kind of like a
lesbian until the,
I didn't know,
you know,
I didn't know she was lesbian,
but I,
I,
I certainly approve of it.
Yeah.
Who was your gang like,
like,
you know,
when you were starting out?
Shecky Greene.
Yeah.
Bob Hope.
Really?
No,
can't come off that fucking old.
Who is my gang?
Uh,
well I think a comic strip.
It was like Seinfeld and Paul Riser and Mark Schiff and these guys.
Uh,
and at the Improv,
uh,
with John Mendoza,
Carol Siskin and enough,
you know,
those guys.
But they were good friends and uh,
I would say was the most famous that came out of that,
that channel.
He was a little bit before me.
I was,
I was acting still.
And Jerry was a standup already.
I paid to see don my rarer before I ever did comedy.
Yeah.
If I,
if I,
um,
had done comedy,
I'd only done it like maybe once or twice.
Awesome.
Nick's right.
Yeah.
The funny was a place,
Joe,
not only did I say [inaudible] Dahmer at next,
I paid two nights in a row because dom could make in one night and his plane was
delayed or something like that.
And Denis Leary,
uh,
went up and that's how I found out about Denis leary.
And Denis leary became my favorite comedian for six months.
But I,
uh,
I paid,
we had some good shows on there where before we were ever friends.
Yeah.
That place is a classic place.
So these people,
um,
did they get fired or did they quit?
Uh,
they,
they said that they were going to leave the radio show until,
uh,
you know,
kind of tell a ship blows over.
It's a tough place to rebound to cause such a small country if not in size,
but in population.
I don't think you can blame that.
Know the guy.
They're just trying to be funny.
If somebody would kill them.
So they thought that they would like have a conversation with somebody who would
it be silly?
I mean,
they've done that before with other people.
You know,
they did one of those with Sarah Pailin.
Remember those Canadian guys?
They called and they told Sarah Palin,
Sarah Palin,
yeah,
nobody killed anybody,
and so they were okay,
but that this is not okay because the lady kills herself.
That's it.
That's right.
It's craziness,
man.
You can't blame these people.
You can say,
hey,
you shouldn't do prank calls anymore,
but I,
I don't think these people should even be fired.
It's really what they did was not a bad thing.
It was a silly thing,
but it's not a bad thing.
The woman was in the hospital because she wasn't feeling well.
It wasn't like,
you know,
like there had been some horrible accident and they were keeping medical
attention from her that was going to save her life and it led to her death.
There was no obstruction of health services.
It was just a silly thing.
You can't blame these people for a fucking site.
I mean,
you don't know it's going to backfire that much.
It's a bunch of pussies.
But Marcy,
Ooh,
how annoying.
Mustak IB.
Apparently Morrissey is a super vegan and not only is he a vegetarian,
but he won't let anyone on his crew eat any animals either.
So the crew guys will like get together,
they'll meet and one guy's room and they order a bunch of Burgers for room
service and they hide and one guy watches the door.
I'm not bullshit and I'm not bullshitting.
And they have to,
uh,
they have to have a fucking backup plan if Marcy comes and finds him in the
room.
I love the honey bit,
by the way,
but never thought of that.
You never thought of that?
Yeah.
If he can start supposed to eat honey,
they're silly bitches.
No,
I'm sorry that I mentioned those guys names because you said,
you know,
I forget how powerful this show is now.
Everybody's going to know who they are.
Well made them more famous.
Oh,
well.
Oh boy.
Do you have any response to dom Irrera calling you a cunt?
I,
Tom and I,
we just need to get to get out of the phone to kill this kid.
He says this,
we bust balls.
Hey,
I was kidding.
Bus Balls.
I was speaking of busting,
I was listening to a,
did you listen to or have you been listening to ONA at all?
I know because they don't have only a satellite in my old car.
You got it.
I have a tape deck.
Why don't you get in your new car?
It was your new car.
Satellite Ready?
Yeah.
Just what do
they do it,
it's really funny lately.
Well it's always funny,
but lately they had on Joe Piscopo.
Hmm.
Oh Wow.
And uh,
they,
you know,
they were busting Joe Pisco boasts balls on the air.
It was fucking,
that was like muscle man think they,
well,
they,
what they did was they played some shit from like the 1990s when he was in love
with this girl and he had like some show and like he sang for like,
you really sang to her.
And now,
apparently 20 years later,
um,
he,
he's uh,
got it with these,
they've got restraining orders against each other for domestic abuse.
They both have restraining orders
and,
and you know,
he's got,
he became like Joe Piscopo.
It became like this weird sort of a caricature of who he used to make fun of it.
Like that whole,
I'm from Jersey,
well now it's like he's really weird become that.
Yeah.
And he tells like these joke episcopal shows,
his live shows places and you fills up these really small places and he's,
you know,
kinda scratching by and try to it.
And it's weird like hearing him get fucked with by Opie and Anthony.
It was like really painful.
Like they were.
Why would he,
why would he do the show?
Cause it gets,
it gets people paying attention to them when people go see him.
Even as a goof.
I mean,
look,
I would go see it if I knew that he was going to be in town.
I would go see it.
Even if I'm,
I will go see a lot of things that I,
I'm pretty sure I'm going to suck.
You know,
if it's going to be an inexperienced comedically though,
you could sit through it.
I don't think it's comedy.
I think he's like singing thank,
he's like singing songs.
I think.
I don't,
I don't really think he's doing comedy.
I think he's doing like a lot of Sinatra songs and shit like that really did
stand up.
He did character pressures of the sports caster.
I'm an entertainer.
I'm a triple threat,
but having him,
he does Sinatra.
Who else does he do there?
The artists.
The comedian.
What does it say?
The comedian,
the performer.
Is that his website?
Bruce Springsteen to snatch a Gella take you to in the audience.
I know a thrill ride.
Every lane follow up.
Yeah,
seat belts.
I think he's mostly doing like impressions and Shit.
Yeah,
that's the thing.
It's like a,
it's like an entertaining show.
Look,
look at him there.
Yeah.
Don't mind me.
I'm over here.
Yes.
If you don't want to subscribe to serious,
I'm sure you listen to some of the clips online like the people take them fans
do and they uh,
they put them on youtube because our show is still on here.
He was one of the reasons I started this probably goes down here.
I don't know all the time man.
The reasons I started doing standup,
that was hilarious because he was so bad.
I was getting hired for Saturday night live and they,
cause Eddie Murphy like Joe,
the only two people that kept,
I got hired by shine that lap.
They change producers and Eddie Murphy
like Joe,
they were friends and they kept Joe because of Eddie.
And you know,
Joe was fine on the show it on him and put him down.
But uh,
I thought to myself,
fuck this,
I can do that.
I could do stand up,
you know,
I became a standard cause I didn't want to deal with the fucking agents and Shit
and you know,
policy or was this 1980.
Wow.
So that's when you started standing up best at the Improv and sad passed right
away because I was already a polished performer,
not to be a jerk,
but I had done so much acting and Improv that stand up all I was really okay.
I just had no act and I couldn't understand how standards had to repeat
themselves to,
to hone it.
That was the tough part for me,
you know,
so pissed Capone never did a stand up and he did,
but he used to do this thing where he'd come in and like,
you know,
you could see right through it and then he'd go,
hey everybody,
I just stopped in to say hello.
Right.
And they'd be clapping,
you know,
like in other words,
I'm saying hello,
which is good enough.
Now if I happen to be funny,
great,
but don't expect me to be funny because once I didn't live,
oh see that's what he would say.
Hello.
Famous.
How famous was he?
At one point I was really famous.
He was famous enough to be on Saturday night live,
you know,
like that.
He was a pretty big name.
I know who he is.
I mean,
I knew who he is when I was in high school,
so he must be,
he must have been really famous.
That was the 80s.
I wasn't one that was 80 for 80 on that was a few years after that.
I don't remember what happened to him after that.
Uh,
he's always a nice guy,
you know,
I mean,
I just,
uh,
I don't think standup was his thing.
He was listening to Ona town apartments.
So brutal.
Well,
he's from a different era,
you know,
he's,
we're a Sinatra era kind of.
Yeah.
And then even though he's younger than that,
reading his tweets about it,
you know,
like,
like trying to like sort of justify it and everything.
It's just like,
he's like,
he sacrifices himself so he can get that attention,
but that is really the only attention that he's getting really.
If you stop and think about it without,
without that kind of stuff,
without opie and Anthony,
they mean they really are helping them out.
And Jim Norton actually like put it on his,
uh,
his tweet,
like,
oh,
go see you.
I'm like,
he's such a good guy.
He's a great guy.
He really is.
He's my favorite performer.
He is because he's so unabashed and unapologetic about it.
He talks about like Midi pussies.
He's like,
you could see like it's a little hands get sweaty and his pod,
he starts squirming,
gets him getting dumped on that.
That makes,
that even makes me uncomfortable.
Yeah,
he's a,
he's not playing it clean.
He's done some wild shit.
Yeah.
Literally I was say I was doing a Jimmy Fallon show,
uh,
about a month ago and my friend,
you know,
some people have no tact and I love Jim,
but you know,
nobody really wants to look like Jim.
Not,
you know,
not that they weren't so looked like me either.
But she says to the guy who's a club club owner of governors and brokerage where
I was playing,
you know,
you're out in the island cause you look like Jim Norton.
He goes,
no,
I know.
I go,
she goes,
yeah,
you do.
You remind me him and I go join and let it go.
Nobody wants it.
If you're going to say he looked like somebody,
say you look like Tom Hanks or,
or not Tom Hanks,
Tom Cruise or whatever.
Somebody who's supposed to be good looking.
You don't see Jim Norton.
You know how rude I know.
You know.
I wouldn't want,
you know,
to somebody saying,
well you look like dot Merera.
You're a spitting image of him.
Nice.
A little puffy,
overweight.
I like that.
Look,
when you see those pictures of you back in the day dot.
Merera the video that we had on earlier,
does it make you want to go hit that treadmill?
Yeah.
It doesn't mean there's Jim
that was a cover of one of his,
one of his cds I think,
or his book.
I think his book,
he's funny.
He's a juvenile jail.
The problem is they have a Deli platter right at the end.
I do.
You know what I do?
I do exercise.
Yes.
The thing when I go to like get my annual treadmill tests and all,
I'm fine.
I'm great in great shape.
It's just the eating and drinking so much,
you know,
and the hours,
the comedian lifestyle,
my friend too.
Happy.
Yeah.
What did Christopher Hitchens say when he,
uh,
he got cancer and died.
He said he burnt the candle at both ends.
But what a,
what a lovely glow it made.
I don't burn it at both ends cause I,
I get plenty of rest,
so that's okay.
I'm not saying it's okay,
but it's better than not rest.
And to take care of your health at all.
Do you like you would take vitamins or do you eat healthy?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Do you know what we just read yesterday that pizza was an antique carcinogen
because the effect,
I hope this is true,
the effect of the melted cheese on cooked tomatoes with somehow like sofic
esophagus cancer,
it was like damn 50% and a bunch of things.
Uh,
you know,
if you can find that it was great cause it's like liberated us.
I know there's a,
a,
there's a nutrient and cook tomatoes that uh,
apparently only,
eh,
it's only in cook tomatoes that it has a certain effect.
Whereas it lycopene.
Yeah,
you got a,
um,
you have to cook it to get lycopene and lycopene is how you turn into a
werewolf.
Doesn't sound like it.
Lichen Lycopene,
you hear me?
You follow me?
Like lupus.
I Dunno.
I'm talking about werewolves down.
Herrera.
Lycopene is a apparently,
um,
it's uh,
reduces the risk of breast,
prostate,
colon and other cancers.
Hmm.
A powerful antioxidant.
Pi Foot.
Christ swipe down.
He has lived so long,
by my way.
Am I right
on that?
A little gravy on this.
Take some humble you.
I made gobbly guts field.
That's when you know they're legit.
When they call it gravy.
My grandmother always called it gravy.
Get him some gravy.
Get degraded.
The only time we called the sauce was,
uh,
was like,
I'm
totally different thing like gravy and also was like Turkey gravy.
You know,
that kind of it.
But great.
We were,
but red sauce was great.
Yeah.
It was never sauce.
You never called the red sauce and you never had white sauce.
Get the fuck out of here.
With that.
What are you a Prima Donna?
What do you want to,
olive oil would call it a fucking massage.
You,
while you have that,
you can get that.
Look at this sexy fish right here.
Jesus Christ.
Sexy bastard.
Look at you.
Look up.
Kills who you are.
I said I love my cat.
You know those people that always have to write.
All right.
[inaudible] material for great.
Wait til I leave.
I'm great and you're being very disrespectful to have a cat.
Do you?
Do you still love your cat?
I'm not going to lead me into a bit.
Well,
if you want to talk to Brian,
he will be at the American comedy company tonight in San Diego.
Right?
You feeling good for that trip?
You feel better and I can feel like I could drive.
Definitely stay there tonight though.
Make sure you stay over there.
Don't try to drive back tonight now.
Don't do that then.
Good luck with the show.
Thanks.
Fine.
And we are
Tony Hinchcliffe.
Hassan's a fucking hilarious up and coming standup comedian.
We've had him on a bunch of the death squad shows at the Ice House.
He's hilarious.
Really good dude too.
Sarah.
Sianna also very funny also.
Very cool.
We've also had her on the ice house chronicles as well,
and I'm now who's hilarious comic.
And if you use the coupon code end of the days right now at American comedy
code,
you get two for one tickets for the first 10 people.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
that's an excellent show tonight.
San Diego,
San Diego is really a,
there's quite a few uh,
comedy,
uh,
opportunities now.
There's two good clubs,
there's a,
the American comedy club and there's a,
an American comedy company.
And then there's Matt House.
My house I heard is awesome and you know,
I liked the little,
well,
and I did a theater though.
The comedy store.
Yeah.
I don't remember the theater's name,
but I did a theater there.
Um,
but it was whatever it was.
It was fucking awesome.
They gas place beautiful.
So happy then they're fucking,
San Diego is great.
I mean,
it's a little weird because you're right next to Mexico and uh,
um,
you get a lot of people that come over from Tijuana to watch the show.
Really that,
that was cool as fuck.
I met a lot of people from Tijuana and they would tell me like,
where we're taking pictures together.
Hey man,
we came from Tijuana.
I'm like,
Damn,
you could just come over.
Like I was under the impression that it was like really difficult.
You couldn't just like go out for a night in San Diego if you live in Tiawana
like they wouldn't let you because they would think,
why would you come back?
You know?
But no,
these dudes,
they were like legit.
They had passports the whole deal and then they win a that's cool.
Yeah.
[inaudible] guys are coming at night.
The radio,
that was the Balboa theatre.
It was pretty awesome.
But yeah,
you can.
Uh,
did he get Viagara here?
You don't want that Mexican for too.
It might not be real.
I got bill burr on the show tomorrow night.
It's a busting balls with Dom Herrera at the laugh factory had a clock.
And so this is your show that people are allowed to come in and they're allowed
to like yell out and say things and what times of start?
Eight o'clock to eight o'clock and it's bill.
Who else?
I Dunno who else on the show.
I just want to make sure I nail the bill.
Oh,
okay.
Because that sounds like it'd be really fun.
That's tomorrow night.
Thursday night.
Well am I go by and watch that as a,
as a spectator,
if you want to say we don't want to spot,
you know,
it's open to you.
I need to start hanging out there.
It seems like everyone is hanging out there now.
Well we went there last night.
Last night was great.
We can definitely make that place do better.
And he was like,
you need a lot,
you know,
like the crowds are small.
Like for the sunset strip.
I mean we'd be packed the Ice House.
Yeah.
And that's,
I don't know,
the fuck got Pasadena.
They had been,
no,
you were going to be on at five o'clock.
That's what I'm saying.
Like we could have a,
we could have promoted that.
Yeah.
Tiffany Henderson is always there and she's,
and she's,
you know,
she's one of the only people that went through that camp that I still call me,
man.
She was hot then.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
Yeah.
Well,
it's a great club effect is great.
If we get another date,
Jamie,
so he can't talk to us anymore to figure out a way we got to do my podcast with
just me.
Yes.
Yes we do.
Yeah,
please.
Yeah.
What we're doing next week.
Last week,
I got a couple of days off next week.
Next week's the end of the world tour.
It's only one day.
It's not really a tour.
That's the end of the world show with a mad flavor.
Aka Planet Rock,
Aka Joey Diaz and Doug Stan hope and great show honey honey band.
We're going to have them on the podcast.
Next money honey.
Honey,
honey,
honey band.
They will be here or ice house.
Probably do it at his house.
His house.
We'll do it at the ice house cause we got the good Internet.
Um,
you ever do Tampa?
Yes.
I've done Tampa.
Bobby jewels.
I did know,
I did all the Improv,
the improvement side splitters.
My folks used to live out there.
They still live in Clearwater where all the scientists Scientologists are.
That's where the Phillies train.
If it matters,
maybe they're Scientologists too.
Maybe that's why they do so well.
I'm doing that in January with his Knoxville club,
which is funny because I can't draw a fucking person in Nashville and Knoxville.
He sold out Nashville.
Tricky.
Why would I sell that Knoxville?
But Nashville is a particularly tricky apparently for comedy.
Yeah.
I don't know why.
Yeah,
this,
there are cities where it's tough.
You know,
it's,
it's hard to,
you know,
they don't have,
they don't have a comedy community and it seems like it wouldn't really make
sense.
I mean,
he gets,
it doesn't feel like it held up on music.
You know?
It's such a music town.
I get,
I mean,
if you're like a really big name at southern that they like you,
they like the southern accent.
Yeah.
And guys like Louie,
who's like a example of a southern act.
It's like Rodney Carrington,
Jeff Fox,
where Jeff Fox goes,
guys.
Larry the cable guy or to Kevin.
He's a white crosses,
a lot of lines.
It then the Larry the cable guy.
Oh yeah.
They love him up in Michigan.
And because he's so blue collar,
you know,
it's so funny.
If he doesn't talk like that at all at all.
And I love him and it's like if some people have gotten insulted because he
doesn't talk like that,
I you will lead me on bar,
Sir.
I'm just here to make some money.
Yeah.
He uh,
I met him at a Montreal comedy festival way,
way back in the day.
Yeah.
Really Nice Guy,
man.
Him and Todd,
she used to hanging out at the West Palm Club coach called comedy corner and
that's where we got to know those two guys.
And then,
do you know Josh Wolfe?
I don't.
Josh Wolfe is a open for Larry,
the cable guy and he was showing me photos of it,
of being in football
arena.
Oh my God.
It's like 50,000 people to see Larry.
He knew it was so funny.
He was.
He was,
he was such a normal act as himself.
Yeah.
He wasn't bad,
but it wasn't good as Larry the cable guy,
he looked into something brilliant.
Yeah.
And he's great at it.
He's great.
He's so fucking badly.
He found that character
muscle fitness with Joe Piscopo on.
It looks like his head is in planted on a muscle,
men's body.
It doesn't look right while he's in fucking killer shape back then,
he's probably Royden.
Oh yeah.
Joe Piscopo.
Johnny dangerously girls like trying to take him down and he's holding onto her
hand.
What kind of a fucking w what?
What does that statement,
why is she behind him?
She should be holding them in front of them.
It looks like they Photoshop the cock out.
It's a weird thing.
It's always a smooth over his deck.
Those were darker days.
People didn't have as many Cox in their life.
Anybody who was on the Internet.
That's my golden rule.
The Internet.
If you have a photo on the Internet somewhere,
someone has Photoshop to dick in your mouth.
It's just the fact there's no getting around that.
I think that's better for everybody.
I was watching this show.
There was talking.
It was that you ever watch that Morgan Freeman show through the wormhole?
No.
He narrates it.
Oh yes.
It's like a Cya discovery or one of those.
Yeah,
it blows.
It's mind blowing if you haven't DVR did folks,
it's a must DVR.
Especially when you,
you know,
like if you're looking for something really freaky to watch two o'clock in the
morning and they were talking about the fact that just by virtue of the laws of
probability this,
uh,
I think that's what they were citing.
That because of the fact that the universe may be infinite and what that means
is that,
you know,
we have a,
an idea that the universe is like 14 billion years old and it started,
there's a lot of people,
a lot of these physicists that actually think that instead of it being finite,
like you can measure the distance of the Internet,
that it might be infinite.
And if it is,
and I have no idea,
I don't understand any of it.
I don't understand how it can be 14 billion years old.
I don't understand how it could have 14 billion.
I don't understand how it could have not existed in an existed.
I really don't understand it.
But what I do know is that what this guy was saying was that if the universe is
infinite,
that means there's not just one but several versions of you exactly out there
just because of the laws of that.
The fact that there's so many variables,
it's like it's like a they,
what they showed is they showed this giant pattern of rocks,
like this huge pile of rocks and they were showing that if you get a like this,
there's like one blue rock,
one white rock,
one black rock,
like in this order right next to each other in this massive pile of rocks,
you're going to have this occur x amount of times.
It's just inevitable.
It just will occur.
And he walks around and he picks it out and then they were starting to talk
about the,
the distance of infinity and the idea of the infinite.
And the idea that if that is the case,
there is so many possibilities that every like one,
you know,
x amount of trillion light years,
there will be another
dom.
Irrera.
Exactly.
Well,
I hope you lost weight.
You know what,
I could just stop.
You know what?
I can't fathom 186,000 miles a second.
I believe the speed of light is,
and they say light years and then they say a trillion light years.
That's fucking unfathomed.
I think it was several trillion light years.
It was,
I mean,
hundred million light years or something like that.
Uh,
I can't,
my mind can't.
We can't 93 million miles as a son.
I can understand that.
93 million.
I can deal with that.
You know,
the Earth is 24,000 miles around 93 million.
All right.
The Sun,
but fucking trillion light years.
Well,
what's really fucked up,
Homie,
me universe is that if the WWE universe is infinite,
when you get to 1 trillion light years,
you're not even like 1000000th of 1% done here.
Like it never ends.
So it doesn't matter.
It's like,
it will go on literally forever.
So how can we get cocky?
I don't know.
How could we help people?
I think,
you know what's helped people get cocky cities,
I think lights,
you know,
like light pollution,
security.
Yeah.
I think those old cave men,
people like they had a great reverence to the sky because like at nighttime the
shit was overwhelming.
Like you would have Sunday time and then at nighttime they were had to be nights
back when there was no pollution whatsoever.
Especially high altitude people where they must've just seen have low.
Yeah,
it's got to be lit up.
Everything.
So the,
the reverence that they must've had for their journey on this biological
spaceship,
this organic spaceship hurling through the galaxy.
I mean it must've been far greater than ours now.
So like as we develop more and more technology that allows us to do more and
more things that make us almost superhuman in our abilities as far as like our
ability to,
to send information and receive information and get questions answered,
learn things,
transmit data,
photos and videos.
It's like unprecedented.
Like it's nothing has ever even been close to this before.
And when you see that,
like it really makes you wonder,
it really makes you wonder.
It really makes you wonder if like while we're doing that and then while we're
blocking out all this sun with all this light and you get all this light
pollution and then we have all this actual pollution where we don't see the
mountains.
You know that weird feeling that you get in la where you can't see the
Then one day it rains and all of a sudden you see fucking mountains everywhere
coming down such that there's a snow cap mountain and you're like,
wait a minute,
what the fuck put that up.
But it's like think about that the the areas where human beings are at their
biggest,
the areas where they're at their most overpopulated,
that's you also at your most disconnected from nature.
You're most disconnected from the view of space because of the light pollution
you most disconnected from the view of the mountains because of the pollution.
It's really fascinating cause that that sort of mindset comes out of the lack of
reverence for nature.
The Moron mindset of the city.
Like that's like the,
the lack of respect for the fact that this amazing deal with nature.
Crazy because it all,
it all happens in this big and it's easy to do.
Like if you live in Manhattan and you take the subway to work and you fucking
buy your food at this grocery store on the block and your apartments,
I looked up,
why bother?
What do you give a fuck if food's there you go,
you pay it,
you go to your job,
you get your money,
you pay for your groceries.
Why even pay attention to where it's being farmed?
Weight.
Even paying attention to pesticides,
agenda.
They can genetically modified foods or who has to go to war to control what part
of the world?
Why?
Why give a fuck?
That's the weird sort of an arrogance.
It develops and some place where you don't,
you,
you're not connected to it.
It's like we're,
we're developing things in these cities where we're escaping the connection of
nature and like creating it ourselves.
You know,
people that have those indoor greenhouses and shit cause something bad ass about
it.
But it's something crazy like why you,
why you got all this food and under lamps and stuff and like in a,
in a basement,
you know,
like that's,
I have a friend who would grow vegetables in his basement.
I'm like,
what's wrong with the dirt?
But you should the dirt.
What are you do it?
Well,
some of it is this because they can't connect.
They can't
raise things in the winter.
That kind of Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Oh definitely.
Yeah.
But agriculture to me and you and kill the climate.
One day I watched those,
uh,
those Alaska shows where people are like preserving all their food and getting
ready for the,
the cold to put the fucking crazy in there.
How did those guys,
the Eskimos and all,
why,
why would you ask him?
Why would you stop there?
The end,
do it.
Whoever the do it,
what do they call it?
I'm not the idiot.
Well,
where it came from was,
um,
the people that came down the Bering strait,
the same people that,
uh,
that populated North America before the Europeans,
they walked.
Yeah.
But when you start,
when you keep walking until you got a little warmer.
Yeah,
I would say so.
But you know,
they might've found like a good check that doesn't mind the cold.
And they started fucking,
they had some kids and they couldn't move to the kid got older and they said,
listen,
I know how to catch seal.
It's just stay here.
Yeah,
we got to make fires every night.
But so why?
We'll make a fire rather than make it glues.
It's beautiful.
Well,
there's a place in Siberia called the Thai Gow and there's this guy,
you mean you ever see that documentary grizzly man?
No.
He ever heard of Werner Herzog documentary and he's,
he got a bunch of really good documentaries.
He's famous for his documentary.
That most recent one was about the,
you see that one about the cave paintings,
the cave paintings in France,
that really ancient,
incredible cave paintings.
But anyway,
this Herzog guy,
he's a really good documentary and he had this thing about people that live in
Siberia and it was like happy people life on the taiga.
And it's all about these people that just fucking trap and fish.
And that's,
there's still their culture.
That's all they do.
And they trap and that pays for like chainsaws and shit like that.
So that,
you know,
the tools are essential tools.
And then from that they,
um,
they,
they just fish and trap and hunt all year that is there,
that that's their entire existence.
And apparently there's like no mental problems.
Everybody,
like people are fairly healthy is skincare to them,
that it's life is clear and um,
they,
they actually enjoy it.
Like they were all getting together and they were talking about how,
what good fun hunting,
what do you want to do tomorrow?
Let's go fishing.
They fished and they hunt.
It's a good idea.
And they have to store up a certain amount of meat.
So from that show I started getting obsessed with all these other Alaska shows
and uh,
the show mountain men were these dude,
this one dude's living in North Carolina,
another dude's living in Montana and other dude was living in Alaska.
But the guy living in Alaska,
it's live in the craziest fucking life because this guy is a trapper and he
flies on a little plane hours into the wilderness hours and then lands and he
has the same spotty lands every year.
He's got this clearance that he's made and he has a trail that he's made and he
is a trap trail.
So he takes this trail with a snowmobile and leaves,
traps all along the way,
and then comes back every day or every couple days,
whatever,
and collects the dead animals and he stays up there from months.
No people believe just by himself in a fucking log cabin.
It's Khorasan like you watching this guy's life and you go,
whoa.
That's where your fucking coat comes from.
Like that is something that's a crazy lifestyle choice.
That's a correct whoever he'll go with,
stand up comedy.
It's gotta be the hardest thing in the world.
I'm thinking liquid his life.
I'm obsessed with these shows,
man.
I'm set.
I'm obsessed with the idea of subsistence living,
living off the land,
these people living off the land.
It's amazing.
And Alaska.
The last frontier is the best one because they got really intelligent people.
That's a new discovery channel show.
They have these really smart fucking people like you're hearing them talk and
like these are not uneducated people there.
They're smart people that have lived several generations up there in Alaska.
They're family was a escaping a war torn Europe and so they moved to Alaska to
be homesteaders.
They got like this giant piece of land starting to growing cattle out there.
So crazy fucking reality that these people live.
But again,
they seem pretty fucking happy man.
You've been up there?
No,
never been to Alaska.
It's supposed to be amazing though.
It's supposed to be some Ma.
It's real game changing shit.
Like when you say like the the wilderness up there that it's a state so far away
they say eagles are everywhere there.
Have you ever seen like any of those videos of eagles like swarming,
like the where the fishermen go?
I'd never seen a swarm of eagles.
It's crazy.
I'll pull up a video,
I'll,
I'll get her out.
Death we'd okay.
Yeah.
It looked for m three g Carter while you,
yeah,
I have mine.
I have it here.
I should lock it in.
Uh,
but anyway,
the,
the um,
what do you,
what are you going to Google?
What's the exact term?
Swarm of eagles.
Butthole.
Yeah.
No swamp vehicles.
Salmon,
Alaska.
They,
they,
they swore,
I mean you,
you can't believe it though.
You're talking about like 30 or 40 bald eagles.
They're sitting on this lawn.
It's incredible.
It's really a,
one of those things that if you didn't see it on the video,
you would think it'd be fake.
But apparently people that go up there and say,
that's really what they're like up there.
There's a shitload of eagles,
but you still can't kill him.
Kill him.
Nichold a shitload.
Not like a gaggle
flock.
I don't think that was it,
Brian.
It was a,
here,
I'll,
I'll go vote real quick.
It's
crazy to watch.
Eagles.
Alaska
Eagles is called a swarm.
He goes on lawn.
Let's see.
Yeah,
but eagles on lawn.
Oh,
how bad are you a Google sign?
You just go eagles on law and first video over 30 bald eagles in the
backyard.
It's these people.
They just got back from fishing.
And so they take these,
uh,
these salmons and,
the salmon bodies and they throw the body to the,
uh,
the fish after they filleted it and like,
they're feeding the eagles.
It's fucking crazy,
man.
Where do you see all these fucking things?
Right?
Pick that one up there on that roof.
Let's go find some bald eagles.
Look at this.
Look at that.
They have a whole yard and all of the roof was behind the yard.
Six,
seven,
eight,
nine,
They swarmed on you.
They could fuck you up.
Oh yeah.
Egos really could,
man.
Look at all of them.
It's amazing.
Those are bald eagles.
I never saw anything like that.
It's crazy.
Well,
people in Alaska,
man,
you get a see shit like this.
Yeah,
you do live in the frozen.
We'll new wilderness,
but you get to see shit like this.
This is a trip.
Now.
This is a protector it up in the last,
Oh yes,
they arm and they're protected everywhere,
but this is a part of your reality.
If you live up there,
look at this reality.
Your reality is you're surrounded by bald eagles and mountains,
and especially like right now in the summer,
it must be awesome.
The thing is like,
look at these kids walking up.
Wow.
I would not let my kid go near a fucking eagle.
I would have a shotgun and trained on those pugs
because eagles have carried off babies before.
Yeah,
that's true,
right?
Oh yeah.
All these executives to just take these children and he is an old picture of an
eagle trying to carry off a child.
There's a video of a eagles killing wolves.
You got to see that.
Look at these fucking,
that kid has no idea how different his life is.
Yeah.
Well,
they don't have any idea how weird it is.
See a gang of eagles in your backyard.
30 Eagles.
I thought there were solitary animals.
I didn't know they flew together.
I think there's so much salmon in Alaska that when the salmon is running,
apparently they'd go bananas and they just all get together and say fuck it.
Ari Shaffir did stand up in Alaska and went salmon fishing and he said it's the
craziest thing he's ever done in his life.
He said it was amazing.
I shouldn't say it's the craziest thing he's ever done in his life,
cause I wouldn't be,
that wouldn't be true.
But he said it was amazing and they would eat raw salmon right from the side of
the boat.
That would just slap the salmon down,
cut it open,
take chunks out of it and just eat it.
That's correct.
He said it was delicious.
It sounds like the greatest Sushi could ever eat in your life.
You think that's gross,
but yeah,
you had Sushi.
I know.
I just don't like the faces.
Faces.
Oh,
the faces.
You don't like the being responsible for the death.
Have you ever killed a fish?
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
We haven't gone fishing and all that shit.
But you always feel bad.
Yeah.
I don't know.
Yeah,
not me.
Not Fish.
I don't really feel bad about fish at all.
I mean,
I don't want them to be tortured,
but I will eat the shit out of them.
And if I catch,
if you hook them button in their mouth,
they already starting to torture.
Oh,
someone sounds like if Hagen,
no history person for if a fish people for ethical treatment of fish.
I like to think of it pit,
if that's the cracks you have about people that only their pescatarians.
Yeah.
It's like,
how do you know a fish doesn't have fucking bad feelings?
Someone said this to my wife.
She said,
uh,
she said,
fish don't raise their babies.
I went,
whoa.
She was truly,
even dolphins.
Dolphins aren't fish.
Oh yeah,
they're mammals.
But she said no.
There's dolphins that are fish to whites.
There's dolphins,
Mahi,
Mahi.
Actually they call them dolphin fish.
Yeah,
I know what you're talking about.
that's fine.
Because I read that in a magazine once when I was just starting to fish and I
was like,
why people fish for dolphins?
That's crazy.
It's not the same dog.
It's not the,
it's actually a fish that the flipper type don't know.
Yeah.
It's not really called a dolphin very often.
It's mostly called Mahima.
Good.
Occasionally on the break,
Casey,
man,
you don't give a fuck.
Dot.
Merera silly,
silly.
He's owed on the age.
All right,
Brian has got to get the fuck outta here.
We gotta send this boys.
It was fun.
I'll tell you son of a B all the way down to San Diego tonight.
American Comedy Company,
eight o'clock show folks,
Tony Hinchcliffe,
Sarah,
Tiana,
Jason Tebow,
Billy Ball now.
And what is the,
uh,
the way they can save some money and if you go to American comedy Co and to buy
your tickets,
if you use the coupon code,
end of end of days,
I believe it is.
Let me just double check the end of days.
We'll give you [inaudible]
for one,
uh,
tickets.
That's what we're talking about.
Folks were talking about end of days.
So if it is all over,
what do you want to do it tonight?
You want to stay home and watch TV or go out and get your fucking freak on.
Okay,
go ahead and get your freak on.
It's gonna be fun.
Should be fun.
Uh,
all right.
we will be back Sunday at four in the afternoon.
It very odd show with a very odd gentlemen that will be Dennis Mckenna and uh,
that will be a,
that's going to be really interesting.
I'm very curious to talk to him.
Uh,
it should be incredibly fascinating if you don't know who he is.
He's the brother of one of the most famous psychedelic adventures of all time.
Dennis can a Terence Mckenna,
his brother and a Terence Mckenna is responsible for probably some of the most
influential works on,
on,
on psychedelics ever
the most influential points of view.
And Dennis was with him through a lot of that stuff and he's got a book on it
now.
Um,
a strange name to the book Brotherhood of the screaming abyss or something like
that.
Sweet Dolphin kisses.
I don't think that's in there.
Hold on,
let me,
uh,
Dennis Mckenna book.
I want to make sure I
dom Irrera on Twitter and as dom I r r e r a
at Don Maria.
This is what's important.
Ladies and gentlemen,
the two Rs is first and please come to see me.
A good night's let me pack the place on New Year's Eve.
I'm happy to go back to North Carolina.
Yeah,
that's a good club,
Charlie.
Good Nights.
We did rally recently.
Raleigh's fun man.
Brotherhood of the screaming your best.
That's the book.
If you want to read that book before the interview,
it might be interesting to give you a little perspective if you're down with it.
Uh,
but,
uh,
Dennis is a brilliant,
brilliant guy and uh,
he's an,
I don't even know how to say this.
Ethno pharmacologist and,
and a,
and an author and a well known psychedelics proponent should be,
uh,
should be fascinating.
He's a brother to well known psychedelics proponent.
I don't know if he's a proponent himself.
He's probably a bit Hedgie.
He's a scientific man.
This comes in.
I'm just a Gamer.
Joe.
Not sure why you want me to come here.
Sprung guy.
Um,
and uh,
again,
uh,
next week,
after,
uh,
Dennis,
which is on Sunday.
Monday we got honey,
honey and uh,
someone Tuesday.
Uh,
I forgot what.
We'll figure it out.
All right.
You dirty fucks.
Listen,
you guys have been fantastic.
Thanks everybody.
Thanks to uh,
um,
uh,
on at.com.
Yeah,
them too.
thanks to a bleed slinger plates.
Yeah.
It's a great grains from kerosene games.
It's available on the iTunes store.
Yeah.
It's only two 99.
And I'm cursing games,
which is our,
yeah.
How do you go wrong?
They're signing it,
losing money by not buying it.
So they're,
they're,
they're the,
the latest sponsor of this podcast and kerosene games are committed to making
all of their games.
Uh,
originally for iPad and I phones and now they're in the,
in the middle of a developing it for the high end android devices.
That'll be January and February.
But it's a cool game.
It's great graphics.
It's again,
designed for the IPAD.
It's not ported over.
They're designed for it and it's only two 99 and they're supporting the podcast.
So go,
go check that shit out.
Throw,
throw three bucks the way,
pick yourself up a dope ass game if you're into some,
because it's entertaining time killing.
And next Tuesday the 18th,
I am leasing my standup comedy special and that will be live on Joe rogan.net
and borrowing from the Great Louis C K it will be five bucks.
It'll be the same thing you'd be able to download at a bunch of gray.
Yeah.
So please don't steal it.
Just go.
I paid a lot of money to make it.
Um,
but other than that,
uh,
thanks.
Thanks for everybody and thanks for everybody to be here for you,
my friends.
And we'll see you all on Sunday,
right here from
the middle of nowhere,
which is the bottom of everywhere.
Exactly where it's just the top of the beyond
the middle of the Infiniti.
Dot.
Merera I'll see you tomorrow.
Rocky.
Come coming back to Duke.
A busting balls with them or I will come back to hang out with you,
dom Arrera wherever we shall go together we shall be like Tuesday nights.
Dot.
Rare is almost always at the laugh factory.
The night's going to switch,
but it's Thursday night for this week,
this week,
Thursday night and close with them.
Or he'll switch to build.
Thursday's a great night.
That's a good night out.
And that's probably go into a Thursday.
A lot of pros like to go out on Thursday.
Yeah,
you can get some fun times on Thursdays.
All right.
Get dirty fucks.
Thanks man.
Follow red ban on Twitter.
Red Ban.
Um,
he'd go to higher primate higher-primate.com and check out my tee shirts.
It's my,
a psychedelic monk and tee shirts.
I don't know how many of them are still available and we sold a shit load of
them.
I over underestimate how many people are buying them,
but we're getting all new ones in and uh,
we're getting,
uh,
we're going to be affiliated with on it now,
so we'll have our distribution far easier.
Yeah.
I'm not much of a businessman,
folks.
All right.
You fucks.
We've got a lot of good shit coming up and thanks for being here through all of
this.
We appreciate the shit out of you and uh,
we love you long time.
All right,
bye.
See you later.
[inaudible].